you
is
[Music]
wouldn't be times
[Music]
[Music]
is at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old motor because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
when i was telling my children
they're smarter than you
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you he's
better than you and he's gonna beat you
[Music]
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
he's smarter than you why who thinks
he's smarter than you why is he smarter
than you
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is lying to you that might come as a
shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers
specifically is
[Music]
harass tyranny
[Music]
look at that look at that look at that
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser he's
a disgrace he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace and he's a disgrace
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't call me
[Music]
wow well welcome everybody it's been a
very
long strange trip getting all the way to
today's rally this was originally
scheduled for friday
and then there were apparently elements
of weather and this kid here couldn't be
there on friday so the entire thing was
postponed to today
and then even in trying to figure out
like what time today
uh
is something wrong with the audio
i think the audio is fine
everything okay
are we good we're fine okay all right
good anyway so then the question was
like what time is today's rally
and it's so complicated because
first of all
they sort of always try to hide when
trump is actually scheduled to speak i
guess because
they assume if people really knew they
would show up five minutes before uh but
also in particular because this rally
being in nebraska there's like time zone
confusion and of course i always assume
that they are correctly talking about
eastern versus central but then it's
like not always clear if they are it's
very hard to figure out when the rally
is but the rally is now and trump's
scheduled to speak
by one report now by another report 59
minutes from now so the whole point is
we're here and we have so many things to
talk about the first thing we're going
to talk about is that the guy trump is
here to endorse
uh charles herbster who is speaking
right now
he has been accused of sexual assault by
eight women now i don't know if it's a
requirement to be endorsed by trump to
be accused of sexually assaulting women
or if it's merely a bonus like as it
points in your favor i don't really know
but the
of the eight women a second one has now
come forward by name
allegations continue against charles
herbster a second woman comes forward by
name
uh elizabeth todson's attorney
claims herbster sexually assaulted
toddson at a fundraising dinner in omaha
in 2019
for years i've struggled with an
experience i had with charles w herbster
at a political event in 2019 herbster
sexually groped me while greeting my
table he denies it okay
and he says uh his campaign says he'll
be taking legal action against the
people who make what he calls very false
allegations against him let's listen to
just a little bit of him i have one two
three four five six seven eight nine
basically 11 different elements i want
to go through with you guys
um
in all seriousness though is the audio
okay
i am i am in the bunker today but
is the audio okay because it actually
i'm not aware of anything being wrong
with the audio right now
it's fine okay i know i can trust green
man he would never say like oh sir the
audio
um
good good good i do have
let me see if i can show this
i'm dealing with my smaller stream deck
today i don't have the big boy so all of
my different audio elements are like
arranged in different pages
and so hopefully i can find them i do
have something very very special this
was a special request i made to small
fuzzy moss small fuzzy moss has provided
us with about 80
of the different audio elements that i
have for a sort of sir
we're calling it like a sir
it's like diarrhea of the sir and it
goes as follows
sure sure are you sorry sir sir sir sir
sir sir sir jerry jerry
sure sir sir sir sure sir sir sure sure
sure sure sure okay so it's com it's
conceivable
it's conceivable that we may need that
today
okay so that's a big uh that's actually
small fuzzy moss has been nominated for
a um audio production emmy daytime emmy
i i mean okay listen it's daytime emmy
but it's still an emmy uh for that
compilation and then
and then i set up again because this
stream deck is so small
i had to be really picky in terms of
what do i need like
readily available and here are some of
the choices because these are ones we
use often obama so you need that
please proceed governor that we need
and we will ban men must have on page
one we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines right
um i like this one get vaccinated i have
one george w bush element which could be
used any time there's sort of like a
word salad
nuclear proliferation and then i did
pool to pull two
classics that never got enough play
which was trump brutally mispronouncing
indian names do you guys remember these
swami vive
come on
and then just in case there is another
toilet rant today i do have these and
you can do that other thing normally all
right the third element of the bathroom
and and i won't talk about the third
element of the bathroom right so
needless to say
i think we're in pretty pretty good
shape as far as uh audio elements are
concerned okay so everybody relax
no uh no no reason to worry i do want to
say thank you to kevin gouldy kevin just
gifted a membership on my website and
his new member number one today and i
want to give that membership to jade
robbins jade is next up awaiting a free
membership if you want a free membership
just fill out the form at
davidpakman.com free membership there
are currently
692 people ahead of you
but that number was over 700 last week
so we are starting to work through it
okay
let's get into some of the meat
or some of the tofu depending on your
preference i do want to thank some
people supporting us on twitch and i
apologize in advance for these
pronunciations
zimerko green man lynn schnarfen
micro kimmy patty don't serp
surf
slip and shank colors
and life is good very much appreciate
all of you
um one last thing
is my video too dark do you guys feel
because i added some audio panels to
improve the audio but that is blocking a
little bit of the light
no okay
it's fine because i could go let me see
if i can do this
is that any better like was that enough
gain do you guys think
does that look good or
it's better now okay
okay good no all right let me turn that
back down
let's see here
a few elements of gain i think i got to
go two more clicks there we go back to
where we were that was a joke by the way
i i have a monitor here i know i know
i can tell the difference okay everybody
relax all right let's let's listen to
just a few seconds of this just to get a
sense of the level of disturbia that
this guy is suffering from and then
we'll move on
far more important than anything else
we'll probably talk about today
is the fact
that you need to be sure
that you know
that you know
when god calls you home
that you're gonna spend eternity with
him right
any time one of these guys says you need
to understand the fact that
it's almost certainly untrue
and uh very very much the case there
okay
let's uh let's get into stuff oh am i
missing some super chats oh dear god i
apologize hold on a second let me let me
get my super chats fixed and then let me
read them there we go
super chats okay nicholas how much time
do you believe the thin-skinned orange
will spend crying about last night's
correspondence dinner uh probably at
least 10 minutes yeah
and space karen says how many bitcoin
you want to bet trump will bring up
elements of butthurt regarding biden's
diss speech at the white house press
dinner i think he will i don't use the
term butthurt because i believe it's
homophobic in origin and space karen i'm
not saying you are homophobic it's sort
of like i had to explain to some people
that you don't want to say gypped saying
gypt is like saying jude not everybody
knows that so with total peace and love
karen uh i am with you all the way on
the substance
but it's a term i would probably uh
i would probably stay away from stay
away from thanks to lisa raider
for gifting a membership on my website
and i can gladly give that one away to
kim grow
kim grow
and then laura says roger stone was
hired by my province to help with the
right-wing party i did read about that
yeah
okay let's because somebody brought up
the white house correspondents dinner
um guys by the way i'm not a uh people
seem to think i'm like a sort of woke
politically correct guy i am not at all
i'm not at all but butthurt
just it it's just sort of like
pejorative against gay men it's i'm
sorry it just is it's not i'm
i just don't use the term
yes egypt refers to gypsies
in the same way that by the way well i'm
not even gonna get into the the jude
story that was that was not a good one
let's do um let's start here so last
night at the white house correspondents
dinner
joe biden dropped the hammer
dropped the hammer on all of the fox
news correspondents in the room check
this out this was well done we're here
to show the country that we're getting
through this pandemic plus
everyone had to prove
they're fully vaccinated and boosted
so if you're at home watching this
and you're wondering how to do that
just contact your favorite fox news
reporter they're all here
vaccinated and boosted all of them
there's peter ducey
looking visibly uncomfortable
yep true story i mean maybe they faked
their vaccination cards i don't know
but uh absolutely a true story you you
really do love to see it
thanks to sabz schuyler and wina joe for
the twitch prime subscriptions
appreciate you guys numbers 10 11 and
12. very very much appreciate it
uh other super chats coming in
none okay good all right let's continue
i just have so much stuff to show you
guys let me let's get back to this stuff
uh okay this is really great our friends
over at the good liars and i actually
forget this guy's name we follow each
other on various uh social media
networks i forget his name i just know
the team as the good liars does anybody
remember this guy's name it might
actually be david
anybody know
anyway this is so good
he like me
read jd vance's book hillbilly elegy at
one point and was sort of like yeah you
know it seems like an interesting thing
to to uh to read and now that jd vance
has gone completely trumpian he went up
in the middle of a speech
jd vance running for the republican
nomination in the ohio senate race and
asked for a refund and it's it's pretty
good i like this president he said
what's the president
um hey jd i got your book okay and i
just had one question for you can i
finish my remarks yes i just want to
know if i could get a refund i didn't
like the book very much all right
16.99 you're going to go
21.
you could have 60.99 plus tax no you
can't
do either of you guys have cash on you
no just 16.99 plus tax
it just wasn't that good i didn't find
that you know the main character wasn't
very likable man that that is really
he's really good and i feel bad that i
don't know his name let me see
hold on a second
we follow each other on instagram
his name is
i just always like to shout out
everybody
uh
his name is
man it just he just goes by dav
i don't know what that means
yeah i'm sorry i don't know he's just
davram
his name is dwight
no this isn't walter masterson davram
stiffler that sounds like it's not his
name okay anyway let's continue let's
just make sure trump's not speaking yet
he's not all right so there's the jd
vance element
okay
you know how many times i will say to
you guys
hey you know um
doctor
now i don't even remember what what's
the guy the the guy who does the covet
channel the doctor dr john campbell
sometimes i'll say to you guys hey you
know dr john campbell's not a medical
doctor
and we go okay okay
this woman stella emanuel
as far as i know is a medical doctor and
she's still completely out of her mind
and here in this clip she says
if you were a healthcare worker working
to treat covet patients you should be
hanged like in the nuremberg trials it's
important
that we wake up even as the nuremberg
you know trials you know and many of
these doctors and nurses and people that
they were they were hung you know these
people they were because they found them
again
yes you hung them again there it is so
there's an idea hang people hang doctors
nurses even maybe pas
uh registered nurses everybody hang
people it's it's very very sick
very sick
so there's stella emmanuel
here is a very odd event this is q anon
patriots arise
and this woman elizabeth eads says that
the vaccines are turning you into an
artificial intelligence transhuman this
i have to hear this is nanotechnology
starting to organize right this is being
injected from from the
bioweapon jabs and it's starting to
organize
they're starting to it's funny
they say covid's a bio weapon and the
vaccine is a bio weapon wait hold on but
does that make sense they're both bio
weapons that seems that seems like a big
waste of time come together and form a
lattice structure which is going to form
an a i actually thought it was a
herringbone or houndstooth structure but
she says it's lattice i don't i don't
know die which is going to interface
with bluetooth and it's going to be able
to track
anybody that took this shot i'll go
further
it's going to be faster than usb 3.0
that's what a lot of people don't know
they're going to be able to track your
heart rate
where you are your location your
temperature yeah your phone already
allows them to do most of those things
right by the way them right them it's
all part of turning you into
an ai transhuman
it's interesting like the casual nature
with which they say these things
it's uh it's starting
it's starting you know the um
the vaccines the uh
the the bio weapons it's uh they're
gonna use bluetooth and then they're
gonna disable your two-factor
authentication and next thing you know
you'll be a robot
it's it's on its way it's probably uh
it's happening you know
okay thanks to skittlestu
skittlestu for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 13 today also
want to say thanks to walt owen
and jody bundrick they've just each
gifted a subscription on my website and
i'm glad to give those subscriptions to
danny mcvay
and eva schlapperski
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
ava ava schlapiberski if you'd like a
free membership just uh fill out the
form
at davidpakman.com
free membership
uh
okay
super chats
when you believe in jesus they let you
do it as a nebraskan i'm embarrassed
thanks for covering the chaos david
thank you i appreciate your support
let's look at a few more things here
this is really good
marjorie taylor green was confronted by
cnn's jim acosta
about her text suggesting
maybe trump should be told martial law
is something to look at
this is one of the texts she just didn't
recall during her hearing
and she barely lets jim acosta get a
word in edgewise one of the things i
really like is she says both
she has no proof she sent the text but
also it's being it's not really what she
meant it's like wait but if you didn't
send it how is it not what you how do
you know what you meant if you don't
remember the text
how would you know what your intention
was
if you don't even remember that it's one
of your texts
this is really good
um
let's take a look at it and by the way
jim acosta this is a really nice subtle
touch jim acosta mentions her
misspelling of marshall as like the
marshall plan m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l
a bunch of times
the power seemed to recall a whole lot
what's going on there
you know jim
you have a show and and in all fairness
you try to present this image of me to
your viewers and it's just really not
correct well we're just trying to get
some answers did you send a text
asking for the president to declare
martial law did you do that you know i
don't recall those being my text
messages but have you read the text
message that is
that you're referring to i did because
it actually says if you it was
misspelled but it seemed to say actually
if you read it correctly jim your
problem is you're lying again right now
it's like why does it matter what it
says if she didn't necessarily send it
right that's the first question it says
i do not know on those things that's
what that text message is
one of those liars on television and
people hate it they can't see in the
liars i'm not the one saying i don't
recall i don't recall it well the
supposed text message require quote it
what does it say
jim
if you're gonna hold me to this text
message i didn't even send that i
remember
you'd better not be taking it out of
context from what i meant when i wrote
it but i which i don't recall i don't
know on those things if you want to hang
on let's read it out let's read it why
don't you be honest for once
read it out loud let's take a look
my question is
what does it actually say okay what is
the text message read the whole thing
let's look at it okay let's read it
but you're saying you don't recall it i
don't know if that's my text message or
not but if you want to talk about a text
message read the text message
do something let's take a look let's
take a look okay read the exact text
message you're talking about i'll read
it i'll read it let's take a look here
oh we got an article why don't you find
the actual text message
let's see here let's take a second in
our private chat with only members
several are saying the only way to save
our republic is for trump to call for
martial law
marshall was not keep going i don't
know i don't know on those things i just
wanted you to tell him i don't know on
those things is that what that says it
says i don't know on those things
wait hold on stop this text message
that's supposedly mine i don't know if
it is jim you'd better get my intentions
correct in this test text message i
won't even admit i sent what does it say
it says some members and then it says
wait hold on it says i don't know wait i
don't know if that's my type it says i
don't know on those things why don't you
tell that story
you're saying you don't know you're
lying
you're
and then when you read the actual words
that tells another story right but
you're you're being awful
yeah
so um so there's that that's it's it's
quite a scene but nice job she was very
rattled there i want to say thank you to
tinda seldarine who is new member number
16 today and huge thank you to jill d
who just dumped in 10 subscriptions over
on twitch also thank you to kevin combs
kevin just gifted a subscription on my
website that's number 27. the lucky
recipient of that one is max bush
max bush gets a free membership let's
look at some super chats here
valerie says david i respect you a lot
you've guided some of my decisions and
thought processes so side question
what's your favorite movie what's your
favorite tv show oh i mean i can't pick
just one i don't know i i'll i'll
mention right now i am watching um
ozark the final final episodes which is
great
and i highly recommend it to everybody
the blah says your problem is you are
just one of those liars hahaha
i i don't know if you're calling me a
liar blah but i hope that was worth your
ten dollars
daniel says can't they find a man named
martial law and say they meant to
declare him some cabinet position
it's an idea
i'm from the uk how did districts in the
u.s work are they the equivalent of
councils in the uk i don't know i'd have
to know how councils work in the uk in
the in the us federal districts hold
roughly 750 000 people there's 435 of
them
um
and each one has one member of congress
do you think trump will mention his
failed social media platform trove
central i know yeah he didn't even get
the name right it was pathetic
hello david and friends hope everyone's
well speaking of outdated terms i
recently stopped using lame to refer to
something uncool i still use lame i
don't it's not problematic i guess
you're just saying it's no longer cool
radioactive dog gaming says i don't
recall donating to the david pakman show
well you just did so i hope you remember
it now
david the best part of the marjorie
interview is her accusing jim of
harassing her like she never harassed
aoc and david hogg yeah
wait is trump here already
with your help
oh no it's just a delusional rant
with your prayers
we are taking nebraska out of that if
this guy wins it will be very bad for
the country so let's hope that
let's hope that that doesn't happen
other stuff we're looking at here's one
more marjorie taylor green clip here she
says women get abortions because satan
whispers to them
it's whispered softly and gently into
your ears and into your soul
and he tells you it's okay
and he says it's just
this one thing
you're just gonna get it done get it
over with and then he tells you a
promise he promises you
all these dreams that that you have in
your heart
and that's how satan sells a sin and
that's how he sells abortion he tells a
woman
that
all you have to do is you're just going
to go to this clinic just going to get
it over with you know
and then you're going to that guy he's
going to stay with you that that
boyfriend or the guy whoever he is
he's going to marry you sweep you off
your feet now
aside from this being completely crazy
does she think that a victim of rape
who's pregnant is dreaming that the
rapist will come and be her boyfriend
like it just it doesn't even pass the
sniff test
it doesn't even pass the sniff test guys
um
it's it's v it's vile you're completely
correct it's completely it's disgusting
absolutely disgusting a couple other
things here um this is
i've been talking about how jamie raskin
democratic congressman jamie raskin for
me now this is just an opinion i can get
along with people with different views
this is what's called just an opinion
i like jamie raskin as a potential
democratic candidate i believe he has
the energy and the fire that i would
like to see in the democratic party
check out this viral shredding of
marjorie taylor green this this is
really good
it's a shame it's a tragedy i yield back
the remainder of reserve
gentlemen gentlemen's times expired
gentleman from pennsylvania reserves
gentlemen from maryland is recognized mr
speaker the united states of america
just witnessed witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle
we are here to debate
aid to the people of ukraine defending
themselves against a massive invasion by
vladimir putin
and his army
then
the minority puts up the distinguished
general lady from georgia who does not
mention ukraine once
she does not mention the thousands of
ukrainian civilians who've been
slaughtered by putin's army she does not
mention more than 100 ukrainian children
who've been shot and killed by the
ukrainian army instead she talks about a
massive invasion at the border a massive
invasion which their own speakers have
said today hundreds of thousands of
people have been apprehended in
that's very different from a military
invasion the one in ukraine of course
the gentlelady's not going to talk about
that
she had a lot to say the other day when
she heckled me continuously
when i came to the floor it was like the
rocky horror picture show in here with
her chanting about the russia hoax and
russia this and russia that
now she had the opportunity to tell the
world what her views about russia are i
put them out there exactly what she has
said she said that the aid that the
taxpayers of america are sending to the
people of ukraine to defend themselves
against vladimir putin and the russian
army falls into the hands of nazis i
want to see her proof
where's our evidence
she talks about
nato nazis
does my minority believe that our allies
in nato who are trying to defend the
people of ukraine are nazis has it come
to this
gentlelady talked about a massive
invasion we had a massive invasion of
our own chamber
and she continued to be a cheerleader
for the insurrection
and deny what happened here
anyway nice job byr i think raskin is a
great speaker
and you know like all the time with
everybody there's no one that will
unilaterally satisfy that will
unanimously satisfy the
the so-called progressive left of which
i am apart right but the progressive
left will never be completely satisfied
that anyone is a
true progressive
tm true progressive
but jamie raskin's background is
actually as a progressive activist
we have a very strange situation with
the sun
where something very weird is
happening that's something we're going
to have to look into
a few other or one other super chat so
in terms of districts are there 20 or 30
districts per state because i hear about
like the third district which i believe
is in colorado well there's a third
district of colorado there's a third
district of california it's depending on
population really small states have very
few people a few districts very large
states population wise have many
districts and representatives it's uh
population based
i want to say thanks to stephen
kopsinski
who just got a membership on my website
joinedpakman.com
i also want to say thanks
to trevor davis
and to judith reeves each gifting one
subscription on my website i can now
give away those subscriptions to
julie strack
and ava shone thank you to everybody
appreciate that derrick says david sir
can we talk about that naughty cowboy
outfit we just had to see and can we do
it in a non-kink shaming way thanks in
advance i don't even i don't even care
what charles herbster is wearing to be
totally honest
he's a complete and total clown
total clown um
let's look at something else
okay this we looked at already okay
let's look at a couple of the things
happening on the ground at the rally
that's always a sociological experience
to see
here is pillow talking about how all of
this stuff he's been doing
is like it's 18 hours a day that he's
working trying to get trump reinstated
check this out dominion and machines a
machine and uh you know it's been a it's
been a crazy year and a half but uh how
has your life changed personally i know
your business like and we'll get to that
special promotion you have for us in a
second but how has your personal life
changed since all of this i mean it's 18
hours a day whereas you know i miss my
grandkids i miss my family you know and
uh and my niece and nephews we i gotta
take you know take advantage of when i
can but it's uh before i was i'm so in
the family it's like i'm pulled away
from my home state of minnesota yeah
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines so that's going on
um
young guy at trump rally says he mailed
pictures of his house covered in trump
flags to trump and trump wrote him back
saying he was proud of him country love
of god but what does it feel like as a
parent to have kids that are so involved
in coming to a trump rally and showing
support for the greatest president in
our lifetime and in the greatest country
on earth i mean just feels really good i
mean he just loves trump he even wrote a
letter to mar-a-lago to trump and trump
broke back i didn't talk about that
letter to me what what did you say is a
cult guys this is a cult what did he
write back it's like
i like bernie as much as the next guy
i i couldn't care less about getting a
letter from bernie you know i just i
just don't care about these people as
people like what i mean is i don't want
them to die but i don't i don't know
these people they don't mean anything to
me
as as individuals or as spiritual
leaders it's just like oh my are your
policies good oh i'll vote for you but
like i have friends and family you know
like
this this is a cult oh no i didn't
really write much i just showed pictures
of our house and the flags that we have
up and then he just said how proud he
was oh okay you know what i'm gonna
actually get away from this i'm
realizing that this i don't wanna
i'm gonna get away from that i don't
even wanna talk about that kid anymore
because
well
it just doesn't seem appropriate
larry says i use the word lame until i
realize that means deformed or disabled
even if it doesn't bother people i think
we can use other words okay i'm not
familiar with that
but
um
little girl at trump rally has asked
what she likes best about trump i love
that he loves our family
yeah
us see you guys too yeah you guys picked
a great one now what is the best thing
about president trump why do you why do
you and your entire family and your
friends and your school and your
teachers what do they love the most
about president trump i love that he
like loves our family what's really sad
about that
is trump hates these freaking people you
know trump's a rich guy from queens who
spent like his whole life trying to
never
interact with exactly these types of
folks just like normal people
um
and it's like really sad that they think
not only that trump is indifferent but
that trump likes them you know
it's really weird
um
i am going to the the glare on me is
getting bizarre
uh so let me let me just briefly fix
that i'll be back in 15 seconds hold on
we need to melt down the voting machines
and turn them into prison bars jack
dorsey should be the first one in line
signed mike lindell
with love for mike now with love from my
jack jack dorsey and you know but you
know what at least now brian it once
again i used the mainstream media
i used them and used twitter because
they were trying to do the corrupt
accounts which was doing damage to me
last year yes it was so now i do this
and i knew they wouldn't that leave a
real one up there right yeah they're
going to hold the rope i used them again
i apologize twitter all you fake news
appearing
he's on twitter all right um
david i don't ask this question lightly
as i have suffered from mental health
myself do you think from your own
political knowledge if mike pillow is
suffering from mental health you know
gamer because of the both the syntax of
your question and my lack of expertise
and lack of ability to diagnose i'm
going to skip the question but i'm so
appreciative to you for your super chat
juni have you talked about madison
cawthorne cross-dressing it's funny
because he's supposed to represent u.s
fading masculinity you know juni i
didn't talk about madison cawthorne
crossdressing and now it seems he may
even be gay i guess now there's pictures
of him um
[Music]
damn how do i even i don't even talk
about this
there's pictures of madison cawthorne uh
man i don't
touching
the the most intimate area of another
guy and saying something about desire
and there's speculation that the other
guy
listen here's the thing that's so hard
about this stuff i don't care who you're
attracted to
i don't care
what you know
gender you feel i just don't care about
it
but
if you're going to build
a cult of personality around yourself by
talking about
what the correct image of masculinity is
bullying others when they don't meet
some arbitrary standard not not only
that you've set
but that you don't even really meet
it's just sad
it's just sad you know
and maybe he's not gay i don't know i
don't care if he's gay that's the thing
i don't care about his cry it's just
he's a hypocrite
he's a hypocrite that's what i care
about guys that's what i care about
uh okay
let's continue because there's just so
much happening what's sad is the
children are getting love and attention
for parroting propaganda they don't
understand it's brainwashing and cultish
abuse absolutely well said well said
okay let me say a few other thank yous
beth graham and bernie on a boat have
grabbed twitch prime subscriptions i
also have a ton oh my god guys we're
about to gift some memberships hold on
let me see if i can find
oh man where is it
it's genuinely hard now for me to find
the things i need on my oh here it is
big massive dumps we have huge dumps of
gifted memberships and i want to make
sure everybody gets gets one here okay
andrew avdrums has gifted a membership
and a second one which i love
and a third one wow andrew really
dumping in and a fourth one andrew thank
you
and then trevor davis has gifted a
membership and another one from andrew
okay so that's six gifted memberships
those go to the following people jos
joseph rose
joss oh wait no that's the same person
that shouldn't really be allowed you
can't request two of them so joseph rose
gets one chris clark
kemuel edmund melanie semple danny mcvay
and justin quickl
six gifts
six recipients okay i appreciate that
appreciate that very much also want to
say thanks to judith reeves who just got
herself a membership so that's 39
and welcome everybody so appreciate
everybody who's here uh trump just about
20 minutes away 20 minutes away and
we're gonna hear from him super chat's
coming in jeffrey wynn says do something
good with this love your commentary
thanks jeffrey
the madison madison catherine situation
is going to cause people on the left to
hate me
if he was to come out as gay i would be
the first to stand up and support him
sure i mean be gay straight whatever do
whatever you want just don't don't shame
other people
new peanut special coming out about
mother's day they mentioned two moms you
know the right is mad about that charlie
brown has gone woke
interesting
with all the evidence the january 6
committee has and plans to share do you
think trump will be indicted sadly no
i got slathered up with cheese butter
and now i'm not sure about the oranges
of my sexuality sir
that's a that is some some message
patrick
jody says i hope there's more of us
watching via the uk
i know that there are other uk viewers
currently jody
absolutely
uh okay
let's uh let's continue yeah we oh
thanks to aj duenes
who just signed up and also gifted five
via twitch really appreciate that
let's look at a few other things we had
a guy at trump rally today said he made
a custom tinfoil maga hat
let's see i have that jacket but it's
very close i want to know about the tin
foil what's the story behind that
tinfoil is you know what this is a
donald trump prototype please please uh
please wear this tonight in fact it's
available for you to wear tonight if you
want to wear it and you can promote it
to the entire country
amazing that all the things that were
called conspiracy theories are out are
now
now with all the truth
we know the truth now
barely coherent i mean truly barely
coherent
um
all right let's hear this one he was
missed let's talk about your platform
while you're running we're running
because this current secretary is not
doing his job
so uh we're going to take his place and
we're going to bring integrity back to
our state's elections
i'm all also running on a bully pulpit
to stand up when our rights our
god-given rights are again
he's running on a bully pulpit
uh violated uh infringed upon denied
we're going to use that bully pulpit to
stand up and rail on the tyrants and
come to the defense of our fellow
citizens and
defend their rights basically standing
up the u.s constitution what what an
inspiring speaker incredible passion
here's a 13 year old kid who collects
trump pins at the rallies pins tell me a
little bit about those
well there are quite a few i got this is
my first pin i got this from mike pence
i'm gonna get away from this one as well
i i think it's in a just from hearing
this kid speak a little bit i i don't
know what's up in nebraska i'm gonna be
totally honest this seems to me like a
neurodivergent kid and it seems
inappropriate for me to even play this
like i mean it's just i i don't
understand what's going on down there
i'm just not even it's just sad yeah i'm
not even gonna do it it just doesn't
seem appropriate
um
we're gonna get away from it okay
lindell now asking if anyone knows elon
musk because he wants to set up a
meeting to talk to him about the voting
machines hold on a second that doesn't
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines i have a shout out
right now if anybody knows elon um you
can you know they um tell him i want to
meet with them because i'm going to be
reaching out to his people i want to
meet with him i'm going to show him
here's what happened with our voting
machines here's what happened do you
believe that because he's got a big
voice right now we're
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
okay so the herbster stuff i don't
really care about
um
okay well i think we got most of that
it's really bad out there guys i don't
even i mean it's just
there's almost not even the words to
explain how bad it is out there
it's it's truly horrifying other super
chats coming in let's see
uh we did that one does trump talk about
returning to twitter i think he said he
wouldn't but obviously he would can we
get trump bingo i don't have trump bingo
for today but but we will do it soon do
you think democrats are failing to set
the terms of the debate when it comes
down to culture war issues yes
yes and i've talked about that a lot
including by the way
on the uh bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad speaking of madison cawthorn i
believe he keeps bringing loaded guns on
planes just because lunatics and he'll
be in his base will say wow look at how
badass he is great pr team probably a
normal guy grifting that's an
interesting perspective larry
the first step in controlling knowledge
is by controlling the words we are
allowed to say tread like lightly when
talking about banning words and books
yeah to be clear guys i don't i don't
talk about banning words it's just like
many years ago i learned that saying
gypped is like saying jude and i don't
say jude and egypt is inappropriate and
the romani people are heavily
discriminated against so i chose to take
it out of my vocabulary
that's all it's not i'm not banning and
interestingly there are lots of people
who have used the term gypped around me
and when i explain to them the oranges
of the term they go i had no idea thank
you for telling me i'm humiliated that
i've been using the term that's crazy
i'm not going to do that anymore
all right everybody everybody relax
what is a god-given right if religion
and politics are supposed to be separate
beautiful question yeah i don't know
you'd have to ask them
i'm a native nebraskan luckily i grew up
in the only population area omaha
anything west of lincoln is really
depressing can't wait for trump's
meltdown today i do think he's going to
melt down yeah
republicans don't believe in freedom
they believe some have more rights than
others
did you cover biden at the white house
correspondents dinner ripping on trump
amazing i saw he said something like we
had
the plague
for four years and then we had two years
of covet after that or something like
that it was pretty it was pretty well
delivered better than i just did
david half the videos will seem
inappropriate i can assure you the
baseline that's the baseline for
nebraska sadly we have serious elements
of bad
i'm sorry to people who live in uh in
nebraska if it is indeed that bad i have
never been
so i can't say
thanks to emily for the twitch prime
subscription appreciate that emily
welcome welcome welcome also want to say
thanks to steve slott
who just got a membership on my website
number 47
and also thanks to joe rader who just
gifted a year membership that one goes
to
shannon turner so here's the way this is
going to work guys
if you want a free membership
you go to davidpakman.com
free membership and fill out the form
there are 684 people waiting right now
if you are lucky enough to be in a
position to be able to gift a membership
okay when you go through the sign up
process
on my website you check this box is this
a gift
and then we'll get i'll give it away and
as you can see above my head the coupon
code sad trump is alive and well look at
that
look at that guys that is just bonkers
really really crazy
but in all seriousness i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this because we
have so much going on
i really would appreciate it if you
subscribed on my website you know all
these other platforms they've taken away
all of our revenue before we had youtube
adpocalypse one and the sequel two we
had the tv bands numbers one two and
three we had facebook
revenue for 14 days all of the different
stuff so in all seriousness
we're talking like a dollar and coins
okay
joinedpakman.com i will thank every
single one of you and we want to be as
strong as possible going into the
midterms we've started uh regularly
publishing content now to tick-tocks we
have instagram reels we're doing youtube
charts shorts i'm sorry oh my god shorts
um
we have all these new things and that
this requires time this requires people
and uh we want to be as as powerful as
possible going into the uh midterm
elections
uh oh and on that note thanks to terry
schwerin who just gifted a subscription
as well and by let me do something else
we're at number 49
next person i will also give a free item
from my online store whether you want a
coffee mug tea mug juice mug water mug
uh
kombucha mug well i can get you a mug
or a hat or a shirt whatever whoever's
number 50 at joinpakman.com that'll be
for you
super chats are coming in like crazy
um a lot of great chats and support for
the david pakman show let's spread this
through your local communities get your
local yokels to get and vote these
clowns out
a powerful message
um
instructor bixby says only sharts
wow
that's a lot
that's a lot
do we have any voicemails yeah we have
we have only a few minutes until trump
speaks let's listen to a few voicemails
let me see what i've got for you guys
the voicemail inbox
has become very very weaponized let's
see if i can find something for you
uh
it's genuinely difficult what's going on
here
a lot of these you guys are not going to
be pleased with
i
the republican ticket for 20 2024
[Music]
trump and putin
yes hand in hand
yeah
all right thank you okay
quite a declaration made there
uh
let's see what else we've got
a lot of very
bad voicemails let's listen to this one
hey david i started from math uh i saw
your uh voter fraud thing for over a
year you said voter fraud doesn't exist
but you want to have it both ways
uh nope so what what this guy this guy
is not a smart guy unfortunately and i
wish he was i wish everybody was smart
i did a story about
a republican caught voting in two states
okay so
the story
that democrats are doing mass
coordinated voter fraud to steal
elections is untrue that story is untrue
it is also true that anecdotally and
we're talking dozens of cases
it's almost exclusively republicans that
are caught
voting twice trying to vote twice etc so
two stories
democrats
systematically programmatically do vote
election fraud false
anecdotally when we catch people doing
individual voter fraud it's almost
always republicans true
do you guys get this it's how it's not
it's not going both ways it's not having
it but both i think you guys get it
okay
let's continue
um
here's one from whitney
can you tell michael knowles that in his
defense i started reading the
um well not in his defense but i did
start reading these some of the books
from um
times
the new york times bestseller list yeah
that's not a list that's interesting to
me i'm not i'm not big on the new york
times bestseller list personally
uh i don't know what michael knowles
might might have said about it but
uh yeah we're done with that that's uh
that's done so my friends
still no cat sharts in the garden no i
have solved the problem of the cat that
was terrorizing my vegetable garden hold
on i think i actually have audio for
that
uh wait a second
where is it god it's so hard to find
here's fresh vegetables yeah um no i got
an ultrasonic
cat repeller
put up chicken wire
to completely enclose my garden
and we're all good we're all good no my
cameras haven't picked up any activity
it looks like we're good
chris says raised in nebraska many kids
here are brainwashed to vote republican
i've met with many who align with
democrats but will only vote republican
because they were raised to do so that's
interesting
oh no the cat is in the chat dear god
please stay away from my vegetables cat
i i just don't come near him
okay
new member number 50 today and the lucky
recipient of a free item is shawn
mansfield sean gifted a membership you
are number 50 the recipient is jean petz
jean petz is the recipient
a ton of people
gifting memberships let me say thank you
to
lisa raider
derek gwynne
terry schwerin
lawrence quartowitz
let me see who else i've got
jason hyacinth
and another one from lawrence cordowicz
that's six
and who do those go to they go to jared
tester chris porter sarah peterson
and uh dustin wilbourne
also rayon pinnock and robert orevec
gifts were just gifting
it's everywhere
i love giving these out
we are america that's exactly right also
want to say thanks to a bunch of people
selfishly getting themselves memberships
that includes
let me let me get these names right i
apologize
sam i am
all right
sean mansfield andrew mcgee
mark mitchell
joey pavellas robert bakarowski
jean del combre
john stapler
uh okay i'm gonna do my best to get all
these correct patrick hart
barbara benno nate williams
amy williams
okay that's nine putting us at 65. i'm
trying to keep up keep up guys blake
daniel sends a gift
and so does oh man can the website even
hold this
blake daniel and cricket martin send two
gifts that's 67 and those recipients are
obvious schism
and nick kelly
sir have you noticed the rally crowds
are always set up in a way to give the
illusion of a large crowd size yes
yes
by the way i gifted a membership to a
person last week and they contacted me
to say thank you it made my whole week
yeah we are building community here and
one of the incredible things is let's
say jody gifts a membership and let's
say you know sam i am
gets it
if sam wants sam can say
thanks for the membership to jody it's
an incredible system we have going
it's it's just a beautiful thing
beautiful thing
chats david the youtube sharts
single-handedly saved me from the right
and now i only eat vegetables
that's i think good good news i don't
know
uh kind of a weird
kind of a weird message
thanks to just call me tai heated bronco
epilepsy dragon tenor lay
did we just freeze i just everything
froze on my end for a second
did everything just freeze
anybody know what's going on
are we back am i back though
oh i thought that we just lost the
stream oh my god
everybody refresh everybody refreshed
that was bizarre
i'm back okay okay good yeah just
refresh if you need to
that was really bad super chats keep
dumping in here i'm going to try to keep
up generosity is contagious says avr
drums yes andrew gifting a bunch are you
going to play trump bingo not today
also love the show david nice to hear a
reasonable voice speak on the insanity
of american politics thank you
thank you i appreciate that
let's listen to a little bit of pillow
attack and multiply a thousand every
single bot group every single media
group attacked everyone i knew all the
way to australia they attacked my
vendors they attacked everyone you guys
stood for strong and you let me come on
your show everybody i would literally
brian i would go i'd be on facebook and
i put up a point last year a year ago
january i put up a picture of some some
evidence or something or say no he's
never provided any evidence
i do want to mention guys it bums me out
to have to do this again
i'm getting emails from people saying i
would like a free membership the only
way to request a free membership is to
fill out the form at davidpakman.com
free membership we just we can't do it
by email so we have to ignore it and i
really apologize for that it doesn't
make me happy
but i've said it a million times
do not email in if you want a free
membership there's a form it'll put you
in line there's an order okay right now
there's 691 people waiting it's just
that's the demand that we have okay
daniel kennedy just gifted one that's
number 72.
so that one goes to john early now we
have 690 waiting but now someone else
asked for one so now we're back up to
691. do not email me okay
do not email me because we just we can't
handle it that way
can't do it
can't do it
you can't request them by chat you can't
request them by tweet you just can't do
it thank you also to catherine
calden blum
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
first time reaching out says tom i think
trump will spend a lot of time on
religious pandering two friends from
nebraska have childhood trauma related
to fundamentalist christian families i
think there will be more religious
pandering at today's speech
number one because it's nebraska and
number two because there's already been
a very heavy religious element here they
were having multiple prayers earlier and
charles herbster was was doing a lot of
uh christian apologia
so i expect heavy heavy heavy
um
religious pandering today absolutely
david sir although elements of lead were
banned as a fuel additive in 96 do you
think there's a correlation of exposure
blunting of half the u.s population's iq
and trump's cult following you know i've
read two things about lead
and
i have not been able to verify any of
them and maybe if people in the audience
know about this you could let me know
one assertion that's made is that
lead in fuel
has blunted the iqs of a large swath of
americans i've not been able to find any
actual confirmation of that
i've also heard the theory that lead is
responsible for the crime waves whatever
crime wave you want find one pick one
there's people saying it's because of of
lead and i've not been able to find
anything actually confirming that either
and is it fuel or is it in pain i don't
even know but i know that there's people
like to talk about lead and iq as well
as lead and aggressiveness and
criminality
now when people in the chat say i agree
i don't care about opinions what i'm
saying is do we have any actual science
on it good science
good science
see a lot of people are saying neither
is backed by science led in the water it
could be
okay so let's investigate
david what's the republican democrat
divide like in your state i guess what
i'm asking is is your state till mo tilt
more towards democrat or republican oh
yeah i've always lived in blue states
i grew up in massachusetts live in new
york
uh yeah no it's they
they lean blue yeah
david did you hear or reach out to the
young turks about a collaboration
i've been collaborating with them for
more than a decade wayne so i don't know
specifically
which collaboration you're referring to
but um
always glad to do stuff with them
always always always always i want to
say thanks to mitchell williams and
robert hunt new members 74 and 75 today
also thanks to blake daniel who just
gifted a membership and that membership
goes to
sasha parthune
sasha parthune
um thanks to g with nate rainbow unicorn
panda guy as well
for the twitch prime subscriptions
did i see the awful celtics game i did
i did
very sad
couple other voicemails sure
let's see what else i've got i'm gonna
do a so-called good voicemail someone
who we're not necessarily familiar with
where we're just going to see what they
have to say
this is jonathan in los angeles
trump actually encouraged voter fraud he
told his voters to
vote by mail and then
go to the polls and vote in person true
that's definitely voter fraud trump did
that twice in north carolina that's
absolutely true
alan vega says can we expect to see you
on leftovers leftovers i believe is the
ethan klein and hassan show i would be
glad to be on with them anytime it i'm
not i don't know that they're in
thinking of inviting me but i would i
would appear there any time
lead leads to fascism as historic
historians have known for generations
when is conservatism ever been on the
right side of history
is being on the losing side and
supporting losers attractive to
conservatives
you know i'd have to think about that
that's a good question
i don't know the answer to them
who's your least favorite progressive i
don't know i mean i don't even watch i
don't watch any shows like mine so i
don't i couldn't tell you
um okay thanks pappy very much
appreciate that
people want another voicemail the most
weaponized one i can find i don't i
don't think i can let me see
[Music]
i mean i've got another whitney
voicemail
so i feel like lawyers try to act like
the law is pretty like hard up like it's
pretty black and white
and it's not
like sometimes like when
somebody says like they're going to rape
you
and then you reported to the police they
won't do anything like the best thing to
do is to stay out of trouble
um
anybody know what whitney's talking
about i have absolutely no idea what
that's about
hello
yeah yeah listening to some of this
dumbass republican [ __ ]
and oh my god you know they're blaming
the democrats now in their campaign
[ __ ] that uh
oh my god these democrats got us
involved in a war it's costing us
millions and millions of dollars oh my
god
you know
uh we do have a kid here who appears to
be having some kind of a medical
incident just against the rhino bush as
someone who lives in texas the last
thing i want in that state is a bush
if you do not get texas if ken paxton
does not win we lose the country not
just texas
explain that explain that take it to the
bank in the 2020 election right before
the 2020 election
every state they aren't they
man what a weird event huh i mean cults
are just crazy
cults are crazy
what a day
uh other super chats are just pouring in
let's see here david what are your
thoughts on your call with the polite
young man from canada yeah that was cool
i was interviewed by wyatt sharp he's a
13 year old kid a
very interesting show it's on my channel
mr sur have been using lead to decorate
drinking mugs for a year can confirm
scientifically it didn't affect my iq
also can i have memoirship yes exactly
you sound fine
david sir i would think this stuff is
the opposite of what baby jesus was
trying to teach a lot of them seem
they downright nuts but what do i know i
despise religion
thank you david for making streams great
again well thank you everybody we are
looking very strongly to
really significant streaming as we get
into this midterm election season uh
but as a as a bare minimum and i mean
this is like just to avoid being
insulted as someone who is not helping
independent media if you're watching on
twitch right now just make sure you're
following us on twitch it's just it it
costs nothing just make sure you're
doing it and if you have amazon prime
and you've not used twitch prime
dump in your twitch prime on the channel
this stuff is all free
we are planning
so much streaming if you're watching on
youtube just make sure you're subscribed
guys this stuff is free
this stuff is free
um and we have like for example
i already can tell you oh wait let me
pull up the stream schedule
on uh
so wednesday i will be live with the
pennsylvania republican senate debate
that means uh mehmet oz and dave
mccormick
and the other three you know um we're
gonna that's a major major race we've
got a ton of stuff friday there's
another and this is actually an
important trump rally i forget what
state it's in but it's somewhere where
there's like a really important
contested race it might be
is it north carolina now i don't even
remember we're going to be covering
debates we're going to be covering all
of it
i want you guys here i mean why not
why not
regarding lead okay i'm not gonna click
on that right now but i appreciate that
uh
okay i think we got everything we need
there
let me give away a few more membership
uh oh what is this channels and now even
banks have tried canceling myself and my
pillow well during these times your
support has meant everything to us my
employees and i went on we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines to you for a limited time oh
god it's a commercial yeah guys you have
two options today and you tell me which
you prefer
you can get pillows from mike pillow at
a discount with a coupon code or you can
use the coupon code sad trump on my
website you can also use the code obama
obama
uh i want to give a membership blake
daniel has just gifted one that one goes
to henry engeval that's the next person
up
very much appreciate that
thanks also to joseph raider mischievous
met
do you guys say mischievous or
mischievous i i've heard people say
mischievous and i i'm not familiar with
that pronunciation but some people love
it
people just on fire with mischievous
nobody knows okay
joseph rader mischievous met and captain
flash heart thanks for the twitch prime
subscriptions
um also people getting themselves
subscriptions on my website dwight
mcginnis
veronica aguirre
marie callahan brown
bonnie evashak
and josh horn
putting us at 86.
other super chats
uh
oh wait no i guess not
okay
we're good yeah trump's due any moment
now
any any second now
welcome badness appreciate the twitch
prime let's listen to a couple more
voicemails i i know the voicemails have
been subpar today
oh here's one about pillow
hello david i'm calling about the mic
pillow
psychiatric crisis in terms of him
continuing to support this theory and i
heard you spitballing a ton of different
theories on the show
i'm currently seven years into recovery
from alcohol addiction and i just wanted
to hit this right on the nose if i could
please um
with mike pillow's addictive personality
it's likely that he is
basically gravitating to this as a
gambling addiction a lot of my that is
exactly the analysis i made last week
guys that that's that's i mean i'm gonna
allow this because i wouldn't normally
allow this kind of speculation but let's
do it because this is also my
speculation and i need to reinforce it
for purposes of ego and narcissism
healthy behaviors and recovery are
addictive behaviors things like metal
detecting fishing things of those
natures where sometimes if i don't check
the addictive part of my personality and
pull away from those activities while
i'm engaging in them i keep continuing
to you know
hit over and over like you would a slot
machine keep digging another hole keep
casting another line now here's the
thing for me
the slot machine analogy is when pillow
goes on stage and he says stuff like
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines and everybody goes
yeah
that's the gambling like payoff that's
the way i see it i think that's that's
where he gets it
um so i think that that's pretty
interesting let's see how close we are
you can tell by what song is playing
record let me look at the time here okay
so ymca it's then followed by that
country song and then trump usually
comes out
so i think we're getting very very close
uh thanks to andrew avr drums for
gifting yet another membership putting
us at 88
that membership goes to noelle
zagai
and
if you would like a free membership just
go to davidpakman.com free membership we
currently have
uh 690
people waiting for a free membership and
i would love for you to gift one and
really make someone's day as well
uh super chats continue to come in what
happened to the patrick bet david
interview i ended up not going to
florida when i was supposed to uh things
just got hectic and i had to cancel the
trip so it's basically just whenever i
next them in florida uh he said look
them up and we will do the interview
shout out to the majority report
backdrop from mr benji
i've seen mr pillow advertise my store
on the local abc station
david do you think marjory trader green
will be allowed to run again in spite of
her perjury i do think she will be
allowed to run again yeah
i love your answers to questions about
the english language so here's one does
it bother you as much as it does me when
people use any more combined with a
positive it makes my brain hurt
can someone give me an example of that
what does that mean anymore with a
positive
i can't i can't even picture what that
is
can someone in chat tell me what that
might sound like
i have no idea what that what larry
means
you know one i really don't like see
let's see if oh god this this sunspot is
making the weirdest thing
i'll have to fix them
well that's weird
um one i really don't like and this goes
back to uh sort of like my my radio days
where someone would say
coming up in 15 minutes from now
no guys it's one or the other it's
coming up in 15 minutes
or coming up 15 minutes from now
coming up in 15 minutes from now i don't
like it okay i'm gonna try to fix the uh
i'm gonna try to fix the spotlight on me
again stand by
rspnetwork.com what's up bringing the
people the truth of america is the truth
if you donate we can continue to do what
we're doing
for you
thank you to everyone and i was you know
i'm not really surprised that this place
has filled up it was a sunday people got
out of church they thought you know what
you know let's go to church put on your
trump shirt and let's go out to uh
greenwood for the rally and then we've
got
a really bad crowd as you know
estimation all right so i think i think
we got it we got it we got it
everything's good
um
anyway i don't i don't know uh
exactly what larry meant there david sir
it's a shame i've just learned how to
use my breville espresso machine given
the outstanding class action lawsuit
against all machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines it
is
let sad see where i was i'm scared to
gift a membership to some troll
hmm
it's not an issue we've had so far to be
honest
david sir how do you feel about bernie
not ruling out another run i'm a huge
bernie bro but isn't it time to pass the
torch to someone younger yeah i uh i i
supported bernie in 16 and 20. i have a
clip the clip is very controversial in
progressive circles i said bernie should
not run in 2024. bernie should not run
in 2024.
love your show david says sherry thank
you sherry
also thanks to peggy for the super chat
a lot of really nice people here today
let's give away a few more memberships
our friend from japan kiyoko awaya is
gifting another one and actually
kiyoko's gifting two
and andrew gifting a third that puts us
at 91 and those go to lisa blash
craig gile and tony thomas
uh beautiful we have really gifted a lot
of memberships today
thanks also to cindersol we are life and
e sandoval e sandoval via twitch prime
and i think we're about to hit 100.
chris henderson and greg tullis have
just gotten themselves memberships
that's 96
and then andrew has gifted another one
that's 97 that goes to eric van handle
lori says is that a gallows with a flag
attached hanging over the stage i don't
i don't think it is
these people are proof that trump is
their whole personality people in my
hometown are still making money selling
trump merch yeah here he is
i've noticed it's been very blank
anymore has to be after it hasn't been
blank anymore i think people mean ever
more i'm not familiar with them
all right so there's failed former
president scrumps
um very very uh informal it is a sunday
so no tie for trump
thanks to eric ostricho
and andrew for two more gifts
those go to teppo nurmi and britta
garcia guys we are almost at 100.
member number 100 gets a free item i'll
send it to you anywhere in the world
that the postal service delivers hat mug
t-shirt
whatever you want okay
next person to sign up at
joinpackman.com gets the goods
jonathan says trump is not qualified to
be president of course not
of course not
david sir my roomba got stuck on the
patio today patio rug where can i join
the class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah pillow will tell you
i'm swedish i wish for a constructive
criticism of our socialist country i do
think sweden needs to do better but i
think the usa can learn one or two
things i want a run-through of our tens
of parties
all right chloe thank you
sherman i wonder if trump will rant
about the fact that the dow plunged 900
points on friday and the nasdag hit it's
had its worth months since october of
2008 maybe
maybe i'm continuing to buy
i actually think the best time to buy is
when stocks are down i'm getting a
discount
i'll be on the lookout for real life
examples and get back to you soon thank
you alright thanks larry i appreciate
that let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think his hair is going to be
able to handle this also blacks for
trump on stage
thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
and thank you
nebraska a great place uh thanks for the
victories that we've had in nebraska and
we've had a lot of them and i've had a
lot of them for you too
it's great to be back in the american
heartland with thousands and thousands
of proud hard-working american patriots
what a great crowd this is we appreciate
it very much
we appreciate it your state had some of
the
very severe storms on friday night i was
going to come i was ready to come the
pilot said sir we have tornadoes we have
sail stones we have everything i said i
don't know
this is nebraska
and then they said you can't do it and
they also had a little thing called a
tornado watch i don't know we don't want
to have a tornado with all these people
right i think that's not a good thing so
we decided to make it today and it's an
honor i wouldn't have missed it i
wouldn't have missed it i could have
gotten out of this one
i could have said to charles charles
sorry i you know couldn't do it on
friday night because of the bad weather
and i heard it was really bad i heard
nobody would have disputed that but i
said i got to come back and i'm coming
back on sunday and that's where we are
right now
see now biden would say i'm coming back
on monday no it's sunday
if i ever made any of those mistakes
they'd run me out of town right
but it really is it's uh these are great
families with us today they're friends
of mine i have a lot of friends of mine
actually right here right here in the
audience and i appreciate you being here
we really have a big thing to go six
months from now the people of nebraska
are going to vote
to fire the radical left democrats we're
going to elect charles w herbster a good
man
a very good man herbster is accused of
sexually assaulting eight women i just
send an incredible slate of true
american first republicans to congress
and together we're going to end crazy
nancy pelosi's political career
once again
you could take the
five worst presidents and i say this and
i say it i think trump would be worse
but you could take the five worst
presidents in american history and put
them together and they would not have
been able to do and they certainly
haven't done the damage that joe biden
has done to our country in just 16
months
16 months of time again think of the
damage that's been caused but here's the
good two and a half did he say a gunt
election and in november we have a big
bread term we have a very big i think
really
one of the most
consequential
that we've ever had because we have to
stop what's going on and they want to
keep it going they'll keep it going
we have to stop it the contrast between
the trump administration's unbelievable
and unprecedented
success and even the enemy says it and a
lot of bad people that we don't like and
you have people on the other side that
we do like
but they all say we had a great success
joe bide and that's despite all of the
witch hunts and hoaxes and everything
else we had to go through and joe
biden's unmatched and
un really unmitigated
failure because it's been a tremendous
tremendous
failure let's look at some of the facts
the numbers and the
results it's undeniable i got gas down
to a dollar eighty-seven a gallon and
even lower in some places
and they have it out of respect to the
audience i won't debunk the gas price
rant for the hundredth time i respect
you all too much too much to subject you
to it again
i achieved what was once considered
totally impossible we were
energy independent can you believe it
you still are
[Music]
they surrendered our energy dominance
and they've been begging for mercy from
opec russia venezuela iran
they'll take it wherever they get it and
we're sitting right on top of liquid
gold
we created the safest border in us
history it was
the best ever and they have turned it
into the worst
border to say i don't think anywhere in
the world you can go to a third world
country i don't think you'd see anything
like it in the world no matter trump has
no idea what there is around the world
this anywhere people just coming in by
the millions and don't believe when you
hear 1 million 2 million it'll be 10 or
15 million by the time that ends and
we're talking about in a short period of
time they're coming over at levels that
nobody's ever seen before we have no
idea who the hell they are where they're
coming from
last month they had 141 different
countries represented horrible we ended
catch and release we deployed i mean
most of those countries are countries
trump's never said are a problem so i
don't know why it would be so bad
members we used to send out of this
country would send them back to where
they came from just a terrible thing and
now we don't do that anymore in fact our
ice
patriots and our border patrol patriots
are scorned
by the administration we built hundreds
and hundreds of miles of border wall in
fact
i don't even know if you know this we
completely finished our original plan of
border wall we then added much more yeah
remember the plan was a one-wall entire
border not even close to go through we
built much more than we even thought but
we saw certainly he promised the wall
would be done by the end of his first
term that almost built three weeks with
all it's all that it would have taken to
finish a phase two
the border wall was a great success and
gave us record low immigration now the
biden administration
doesn't know what to do or do they know
what to do
that's even scarier if they do know what
to do welcome to everybody joining us on
twitch from rose wrist i admit i don't
know what roe's wrist is but welcome
everybody
space force
75 years not since
not since the air force
they gave 85 billion dollars of our
military away to the taliban you
remember that the press doesn't like
talking about it they don't mention it
including
700 000 machine guns rifles and other
firearms think of what 700 000 i don't
know if you know it they're one of the
biggest
sellers of equipment now guns rifles
planes
munitions
one of the si the biggest anywhere in
the world they're selling the stuff
whoever knew the term munitions before i
was president but they said no sir it's
munitions it's what we call them and i
said what the hell let's sell them some
munitions
trucks does anybody here own a car
place or does anybody have a used car
lot 70 000
trucks many of them are armor-plated
very expensive of course millions and
millions of dollars
and they gave it away for nothing for no
reason they wanted to get out they took
the military out first
it's a horrible think of what happened
they took the military out first
i was getting a safe to provide a little
bit of sanity trump was interviewed
multiple times and said
what exactly would you have done
differently than joe biden and he wasn't
able to actually articulate any
differences in terms of the withdrawal
from afghanistan added billions and
billions of dollars were spent many
years ago building it and we walked out
at the dead of night and did leave the
dogs behind by the way they were left
behind the dogs
we were getting out of that we were
getting and we were going to get out
with dignity and power and strength that
we weren't going to lose
soldiers we had 13 killed many many
injured nobody even talks about the
injured no arms no legs
blown to pieces
and uh just so sad to see i think it was
the lowest day in the history of our
country that lo that time period in the
media actually the day trump won in 2016
was much higher i would say the two and
we did we ended the endless wars there
were endless wars but we made them
ending
and bringing our troops we brought them
back home
biden turned afghanistan into
truly
something that nobody ever thought
possible in fact i think putin
when he looked at that he said this is
the time to go in because in my watch he
wouldn't have done it he would have
never ever done it
he saw the weakness he saw the
incompetence
none of this would have ever happened
100 somebody said are you sure well we
went through four years plus if you
think about it plus a very long
time where we were politicking right
nothing happened four years nothing not
even a question about it and i spoke to
him about it he knew how i felt he
wouldn't have done it that's a shame
unto so many people being killed the
whole place is just a disaster that
whole mess what a mess and it should
have never happened on tuesday biden's
going to
the javelin factory they build the
javelins remember the javelins with tank
busters
it's in a great state alabama boy we
want alabama too we want alabama so big
the same weapons that i supplied to
ukraine while the obama bike trump
bragging about winning wildly red states
with the heat i took i was supplying
javelins and they were saying it was
good he gave blankets i gave javelins
and they were saying like oh
it's supposed to be good the other way
well it turned out that without the
javelins there wouldn't even
be anything going on there
i remember this i ended the pipeline
i supplied the javelins and i got 430
billion dollars more for nato from these
other countries that were delinquent
they weren't paying
and then i had to listen to these people
up here the fake news
say he's been so nice
he's been so nice to russia
russia
you know who didn't think i was nice to
russia putin he said you're killing me
on the pipeline
the people of alabama that never know
what's going on when he shows up on
tuesday the people of alabama know we
gave it you know they're always
trying to take what we did and trying to
say gee they did it it's all
misinformation their whole party is
based on misinformation everything from
russia russia right projections
to the laptop from hell to the
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two
the mueller [ __ ]
it's all
[Music]
it's all they're a party they are the
party of misinformation under my
leadership america was you really
couldn't have a more accurate criticism
of his party it's it's wild we were
respected
we were respected now leaders of other
countries don't even return
the phone call of the president of the
united states i don't want to talk to
him
totally they want in many cases nothing
to do with them other than to take
advantage of us like we're giving 33
billion dollars
what's europe giving you know europe is
very affected by what's going on over
there you know what they're giving
they're giving a lot of lip service by
comparison
a lot of lip service
under the trump administration we had
the greatest economy in the history of
the world there was never an economy
like we had pre-covered the china virus
isn't the unemployment rate now lower
than the bottom under trump just to like
to pick one
factor it started now it's a raging
tiger but it was caused and started by
energy prices you look at it but now
it's a raging tiger now you look at the
food you look at everything food is
worse than energy
what has gone up anybody buy some bacon
lately i hope trump talks about when he
went to the grocery store they think
it's a misprint
it's quadruple they think it's a
misprint they look at the person oh
isn't that cute they made a mistake
somebody made a mistake david biden
created the worst inflation in much more
than 40 years and it's going a lot
higher get used to it it's probably
going to start declining in two months
hey is my video too dark now that the
sun is setting
then any tax increase that any
government any party anybody could ever
imagine
proposing inflation is a disaster
first they said it was transitory
now they say it's putin's fault it's
putin's fault
let's blame putin why the hell not right
it's putin's fault
i gave you the largest tax cuts and tax
reforms and regulatory reforms in
history
the radical democrats intend to impose
the largest tax hike in the history of
our country if they get any of this
stuff done it'll be the largest tax
increase in the history of our country
they're working feverishly to put them
all back all of those restrictions that
we took off
including what you did and what i did
for the farms and the farmers where you
couldn't even use your land you couldn't
even touch your land
if you had a little puddle in your land
they considered it a waterway
say no darling that's a puddle that's
been there for a long time no no that's
considered a lake and you can't do a
damn thing and they want to pile on more
and more restrictions and i'll tell you
when i
signed all of that
nonsense out people really appreciate it
and the people of nebraska appreciate it
and i appreciate them
we created seven million new jobs that's
a record we had another record we had a
hundred remember that the rate of job
creation is faster under biden than
under trump seven million people of food
stamps lifted 10 million people off
welfare nobody's ever seen numbers like
that
nobody's ever seen it
under biden there are still millions
fewer jobs than before the pandemic
millions and millions far lower than
164.
million people way way lower and a lot
of people in all fairness are just not
going to go back to work all right let
me know in the chat do you think trump
will do his toilet rant today
yes or no
have declined 12 months in a row now
think of that real wages have declined
they have a thing called the misery
index it's at the highest level ever
recorded
and the economy shrank to one point and
shrank by think of this
1.4 percent in the first quarter
nobody's ever seen that but you don't
hear it because the faith is these
people right here they don't want to
report it
you saw it like 14 years ago
and you know a lot of times see the red
lights on the cameras all those cameras
a lot of times when they see them going
there or i'm going to someplace else so
i'm going to talk about the rigged and
stolen election the cameras go off
charlie turn off the cameras this is a
total lie only right-wing media is there
corporate centrist and liberal media
that brings cameras they're not covering
this only right-wing media is there this
success with therapeutics and operation
warp speed which everybody said to this
day was one of the most incredible
things ever done by government
i rejected mandates i rejected
unscientific lockdowns
and i fought together notice when he
when he brags about the vaccines he
doesn't use the word vaccine he says
operation warp speed and even then the
applause is very sparse
in fact
i'll say it's science
you know the way they say it's science
remember
remember falci when he said no no nobody
should wear a mask then three months
later he became a radical massacre if
you could wear seven put them over your
eyes put a couple over your mouth your
nose
masks all over your face
but at the beginning he said masks are
now good importantly i let
republican governors run their states
the way they should remember initially
the concern was
uh
that there would be no supply for
medical professionals it was like 10
days later they were like get masks
supplies of all shape sizes and kinds to
them
and without cost we got them we did an
incredible job in getting them equipped
remember when
they got credit
for doing a great job
the democrats they get oh didn't he do a
wonderful job in kobe he couldn't even
get tests out couldn't get anything out
it's because
they just took the credit disinformation
remember it the party remember speaking
of disinformation
under trump the u.s was one of the
slowest to ramp up testing and trump
actually said slow testing down
if you don't have tests you don't have
cases sort of like if you don't have a
pregnancy test you're not pregnant
impose horrific mandates
punishing lockdowns and radical mask
regulations now you know they always say
oh didn't he do wonderful actually
they're not saying that too much even
these guys don't get away you know
didn't do he'd do wonderful in covet i
call it the china virus does anybody
mind if i call it
koga
right
you know in 1917 they had the spanish
flu nobody
said gee don't call it the spanish flag
there was a reason it was called
well it's a china virus whether we like
it or not and i was also right about
i was also right about wuhan the labs in
wuhan i was right about
i think i was right about everything
there's no evidence of that actually
wow dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you guys think 1500 people 2500
maybe he's going to hell
but we'll turn it around we're going to
turn it around i just hope
i just hope it's not going to be too
late in some respects because what
happened in ukraine is very dangerous
this could be a very dangerous thing for
the world
this could end up being a world where we
have incompetent people running things
it could be end up being a world war
and we have two and a half years to go
we have fortunately not too long to go
to the midterms but we have two and a
half years to go for the presidential
election and i never realized how
important being president was until i
watched what's happening now where we
have somebody that goes over to europe
europe
and embarrasses our country embarrasses
our country
come here joe come here stand up here
wave joe wave to the crowd joe
paris is our country
thankfully
[Applause]
what are they saying is it joe's gotta
go oh my god the crowd is three million
people i miscounted sorry guys
very dangerous period of time thankfully
a trump appointed judge recently struck
down biden's ridiculous mask mandates
and a righteous victory for american
freedom
joe biden and the radical left have
turned calm into chaos competence into
incompetence
stability into anarchy prosperity into
poverty and security into
catastrophe otherwise they're doing a
fantastic job
the election was rigged and stolen
and now our country is being destroyed
because of it such stupid decisions are
being made
including the border including
afghanistan
we had it all set to come out we would
have come out with dignity and pride
i was ready to get us out but then i
lost and then biden got us out just like
i said and he's terrible you kill any
more soldiers we're gonna hit you so
hard you
you know nobody will ever be hit
nobody will ever be hit
like you're going to be hit
and he said i understand your excellency
he called me your excellency we didn't
lose one soldier in 18 months think of
it unlike chicago and these democrat-run
cities
we didn't lose one soldier in
afghanistan until this tragedy of the
way they left the way they got out i'm
the one that set it up to get out i
brought it down all the way down to 2000
soldiers they were going to stay there
until we got our hostages because i call
them hostages we have still hundreds of
people in there
oh this story again just remember guys
the question is when asked did trump
identify anything he would have actually
done differently than joe biden and he
was unable to identify a single thing
the day
97 should not have been
coming out and in that group you have
terrorists you're going to be paying a
price for a long time for what they did
three percent of the people were
entitled to come out they rushed the
airplanes 28 people fell off the side of
the airplanes from 3 000
feet up that's three times the height of
the empire state building they fell off
the side of the airplanes 28 people this
is the most dangerous time in the
history of our country because of the
incredible
power of modern day weaponry which we
totally rebuilt including our nuclear
not that i wanted to i hated to rebuild
the nuclear but we have no choice
because others are doing it
meanwhile we have a president who has no
idea what's happening by the way this
couple in the fjb hats
don't they seem riveted you can tell
that this is just such an inspirational
speech to them talked about nuclear
weapons you're not supposed to talk
about nuclear weapons the n-word i used
the word i used the term the n-word they
went crazy he said the n-word i said
yeah the nuclear word you don't talk
about the nuclear word you just don't
talk about it it's too devastating to
talk about he's throwing it around all
the time because he doesn't respect our
leadership
just look at the video of joe biden
attempting to speak last week very tough
to russia and putin take a look at this
of uh that will enhance our underlying
effort
to accommodate the russian oligarchs
and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them we're
going to seize their yachts their luxury
homes and other ill-begotten gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy
wow they're they're making a fun of a
guy in front of a guy with a stutter
they're making fun of a guy with a
stutter from who's stuttering
wow
[Applause]
and it got worse but we
don't have all afternoon to it
once and for all joe biden should put
the question to rest by taking a
cognitive test you have to do it and
releasing the results for the entire
world to see when the fake news started
saying fake crap about me i said to uh
doc ronnie who's now as you know ronnie
jackson he's a great congressman from
texas he's so popular
he's the most popular guy he's doing the
dementia rant doctor he was an admiral a
great admiral he was a highly respected
man he was the doctor for bush
he was for
let's see he was forever he was for bush
and obama and he was for me and i said
so who's the healthiest of the group
obama doc ronnie said uh he likes me he
said you are sir you're the perfect
specimen that's right you said
sure i said what about obama he's in
good shape sarah you're the most healthy
guy i love dr ronnie i love dr karani
but i said what do you think about a
cognitive test ronnie
he said well you know the problem is you
know you're dealing with walter reed
it's very public
and you have other doctors watching and
if you do badly i you know the word's
going to get out or we'll probably have
to announce it
i said how tough is this test ronnie
because these people are calling me bad
names they're calling me stupid
they're stupid right i wasn't exactly
gonna end this [ __ ]
so i said how long
and how tough is the test they say well
the first questions are easy but when
you get to the middle of the test
they're very hard yep and at the end of
the test you know a lot of people have
no clue they can't answer those
questions they're tough it's a basically
tough test you know it gets easy and
then it goes up
and uh
so what do you think ronnie said i don't
know it depends how do you doing this
stuff i said okay i do good i do good
smart guy i'm actually real smart ronnie
wow
let's go ronnie let's go so they gave me
the test
and he will tell you i aced it every
question right
people are cheering a dementia test guys
that's a dimension he said i've never
seen anybody ace it before i said i aced
it
i aced it and they got you know it's
really a good thing because they no
longer called me stupid
you know
they no longer call me stupid now they
say he's a dictator who wants to take
over the world
they say all sorts of other but they
don't call me stupid anymore but i think
it's something that a presidential
candidate or president should take you
know you're representing you see the
damage caused right now by what's
happening and i think it's something
that you should take
it's something you should take and i
support it wholeheartedly dementia tests
for everybody
see that would normally be breaking news
but they won't report it but i think
everybody should take it everybody that
even runs should take it you should have
a
certain standard you know not to equate
us with china
but i'll tell you what they have uh a
very tough system you start off all even
when you're about two years old he
always is he's impressed by it by strict
authoritarian regimes thing and i will
tell you president she's a very smart
man
whether you like him or not and you
notice that during four years he didn't
attack taiwan
never thought of it now all of a sudden
they have a lot of bombers flying over
taiwan they're looking i think the only
thing that's going to stop him is he's
going to look at the mess that russia
got himself into and he might say
he might say
charles
are you doing good looking at me sitting
there with that beautiful hat on i'd
love to wear a hat like
charles w good man
he's been maligned he's been maligned
well he's been accused credibly by six
women of sexual assault
i come out i defend people when i know
they're good he's a good man
i came out here
a lot of people i mean this is the way
david bossy right is the way it it works
i mean it's uh
a lot of people they say and they look
at you and they say well you don't have
to do it sir you could i have to defend
my friends i have to defend people that
are good he was with us from the
beginning i just met so many people back
saying thank you sir for being here he's
been my friend for 30 years he's the
most innocent human being he's the last
person to do any of this stuff and even
the stuff they're accusing of what they
say he talked to somebody yeah trump's
like i've been accused by 46 women of
way worse stuff than the ace eight women
accusing him this is nothing i could
have gotten out of this one real easy i
could have played golf i could have gone
to the beach i could have done and i'm
here with charles w
charles w herpster
herpster
kind of like herpes that's an
interesting pronunciation herpster
i said charles are you sure i have to
come please sir i'd like it to come it's
so unfair and his friends called me they
said i'd like you to come because it's
so unfair
and we can't let this stuff happen
you know and by the time he clears
himself the election's over they'll say
oh it was right remember that whole
thing with hold on very bad people when
they were talking about the tax returns
and they lose the election and after the
election the guy said well we won the
election didn't we even though it was
totally made up that was about a guy
named a rhino named mitt romney
romney
[Applause]
he's a real beauty that guy but remember
they said all sorts of bad things about
his taxes and then he lost he got his
ass kicked actually
he ran a horrible campaign remember the
respect he had he respected obama so
much i said why did you salute him i
mean he was just all in for
he it's tough when you're all in for
somebody that you're running against
he was all in but they lied about his
taxes they said horrible things about
his taxes
and when they went to harry reid i guess
it was right yeah they went to harry
reid and they said his taxes were racist
and sexist taxes he goes we won didn't
we
that's the way they play the game
cpac
is a great organization we have a
a great gentleman here but i'm going to
introduce him i'm not going to talk
about him now because he's going to
he's going to
come up and maybe even say a few words
he's been great he's been a supporter
and i want to i want to thank all of the
people from cpac
that are here trump seems disoriented
now like he's not even sure what he's
supposed to be saying romney and it
happens to others oh by the way it
happens to me on a daily basis all this
stuff they make up crap like nobody's
ever seen but you know what it hasn't
been so effective i got more votes than
anybody's ever gotten can you believe it
i'd got one
any president no president has ever gone
with the support of all of the patriots
here tonight
we saved our country once and together
we will
save our country again
is that right matt schlapp what do you
think matt schlapp we're going to save
our country again matt
[Applause]
it's all pretty strange i'm not going to
lie
all we need is a house a senate and a
president who will
very simply put america first and we did
that we put america first so we had
people fighting us remember when they
first came in we will not support
america first i said you know what such
a great name even if you don't support
what we do and that's what it is it's
america first you don't say that we're
not going to support say we don't
support trump we don't support his
policies but you don't say we will not
support america first i used to love it
they change after about one week they
were getting hammered what's he talking
about i ran twice
i won twice and did much better the
second time than i did the first yikes
we got 12 million more votes than in
2016.
and likewise
we got more votes i just said it i'll
say it again and again and again than
any president in the history of our
country by far he can keep saying it
it's not true you may have to do it
again
and joe biden didn't get votes he got
ballots i certainly get he got ballots
where the hell did they come from where
did all those ballots come from by the
millions and millions they poured in
what a lot of what a hoax
the ultimate con and they hate to talk
about it you know they don't want to
talk about it
and i want you to see uh david basi's
citizens united they did an incredible
documentary on
417 million dollars and coming out
i guess tomorrow or the next day is
dinesh right dinesh de
a movie but it's not about the movie
it's about truth to vote they're coming
out with their findings these are
thousands of patriots that went around
the country viewing tape you know all
those fake tape boxes not the lock
they're unlocked boxes
because you unlock them i wonder what
they did when they were unlocked but i
call them the unlock boxes they have
tapes of all those boxes and these
incredible
women headed up by katherine engelbrecht
who's an incredible patriot she uh they
went around and they
looked at miles and miles of tape man i
have to tell you these two really don't
seem like they're having a good time
like really really not at all
phony votes
and you know what's going to happen
maybe nothing
you know maybe nothing isn't it sad
the fake news doesn't want to talk about
it they don't want to talk about
anything bad
for the democrats they don't want to
talk the biggest thing they don't want
to talk about though is the election
because they know the result and they
don't want it it's too close we're too
close we're not too close we know the
results you know the biggest lie of all
is when they say the big lie do you ever
see these stories when these fakers they
write stories and they say well there's
absolutely no proof we got truckloads in
every state wisconsin you see what's
going on they have literally nothing 63
court cases that courts said you have
nothing facility supported supposedly
voted
but in years past very few people voted
you know why they have other problems
they don't care about trump i don't
blame them they want to live they can't
breathe one person came up my mother's
comatose she hasn't been
able to speak for over a year
and they're saying she voted in the
election
this is so dumb she didn't care about
the election she has much bigger
problems but they had almost a hundred
percent of the people in wisconsin
voting and they have a man justice
gableman a very highly respected man
he's fantastic he's a fantastic man and
he's he's issued a report that's just so
horrible so damning as to we're like a
third world country and we're third
world with the press too because they're
among the most dishonest remember
there's only right-wing media there and
he's pointing at them and attacking them
our main papers almost every sentence
every time they talk about the election
while nothing has been proven while this
it's all out there it's there and this
one's going to be interesting because
david was great what he did with a 417
million how it went to mostly democrat
areas and i can't believe it's legal
david i just can't believe it but when
you watch this one that's coming out now
and i'm not necessarily talking about
the movie or the documentary but that
covers it to an extent but they have
much more even than that anybody know
what he's talking about things next week
or the week after
millions and millions of votes and
therefore it's coming out next week or
the week after and it's not necessarily
in the movie or the documentary but it
is to some extent oh wow people the
corrupt people but the swing states were
devastating and the information they
found was devastating and i could go
over things like left and right when you
look at what happened in detroit
was so bad philadelphia was so bad
atlanta
was so bad that governor did nothing i
got him in when i endorsed him i got
this guy elected he did nothing and one
thing has nothing to do with the other
but i'll tell you what he did nothing
for the people of georgia the people of
this country he didn't want to know
about it i think he was embarrassed by
how bad it was and he didn't want it
down on his watch and that's not what
it's about and frankly
if he did the right thing it would have
been a positive for him it would have
been a positive he's like afraid of the
stacey abrams i don't know what the
hell's going on there but he's done sex
what happened is biden won and so he's
been ranting for two minutes what
happened is biden won and trump's mad
because he's in there fighting he got he
would have been a senator i mean except
for the horrible corruption you look at
fulton just take a look at what took
place in fulton county it's a horrible
thing that took place so
it was all too corrupt who's having the
least fun on stage i know this couple's
fighting and they seem to not be having
a good time this kid doesn't seem to
exactly be thrilled
this kid person
is not having a particularly good time
um
there's just a lot of people not
enjoying this it would have been very
easy
to lose you lose somebody when somebody
loses what's very hard is when you get
more votes than any sitting president in
history by far when if you got other
than the guy you ran against four years
before
you went easy they say
all the they said well if you got the
same obama got fewer votes the second
time and he won
very easily i mean the person he was
campaigning against wasn't that good but
he won very easily
i got far more votes than we got the
first time that meant you know that
means that i did a good job
so
honestly
when you lose the election you know hey
look you know i gave it my best and you
say i gave it my best and we worked hard
and we lost i would have loved to have
congratulated
a person this is maybe the deadest crowd
he's had in a very long time i think 10
of the people on camera here are asking
to leave but it was a rigged election
and he didn't win not only didn't he win
he lost by a lot and you saw so many
different things where he got more votes
with the
african-american community than obama
give me a break
in certain locations give me as always i
love how he adds in certain locations
that's like a like as an aside i mean
just point after point many different
things so
ballot harvesting is coming out next
week that's determinative
that's election changing that's next but
there are many other things that were
also election changing matt schlapp
worked in nevada
and he went in there very skeptical he's
completely lost all momentum it's
actually fascinating there's no momentum
here the crowd is dead
reading it would have said wow
but you couldn't believe it right he
became a believer then he wasn't a
believer maybe
the first day or the second day but
after he saw all the he literally went
there to look at it
and he studied at cpac
and he said man this thing was really
corrupt but we had a judge that didn't
even want to look at it we had many
judges without any courage they didn't
want to look at it they didn't want to
talk about it including our supreme
court of the united states
including them
what they did was are almost 20 states
filed because listen to this system the
president of the united states has
doesn't have standing i'm the president
of the united states i just went through
a rigged election and i have no standing
so i can't file a case they say i can't
file
but the states can file
so 20 states almost 20
and god bless
the united states the people i will tell
you and i think that attorney general is
doing very well in texas
he's got his uh race
coming up
in a very short period of time i think
he's going to do by the way 33-0 in
texas i was three on endorsements 33-0
and you know if i lost one race they'd
say trump was humiliated that's what
they're waiting for they're waiting for
one race you know we've endorsed dr oz
we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great hold on
isn't it jd vance and what's mandel's
last name he's confusing two different
people
what's the man jd mandel jp jd
it's it's it's jd vance and josh mandel
what the hell is he talking about
i think vance is doing well i think oz
is doing well does everybody like us i
love us
he cares i think he's going to also do
better in the general election so you
know there are a lot of reasons to
endorse people
guys like mitch mcconnell and rhino
friends would rather see a democrat like
biden be president than a republican
like me i'm a little bit different kind
of a republican we want to get things
done
it sort of works better for him and his
agenda but it doesn't work well for our
country
he should have done something about all
of the things that we were just talking
about with a rigged election
when a thief robs a jewelry store and
gets caught they have to give the
jewelry back right they have to give it
back they don't keep it
so here they're saying we found all of
these uh
all of this fraud and all of these
irregularities yeah the the the memit oz
primary in all seriousness is very
important that race the pennsylvania
race could decide who controls the
senate and so we will be covering the
the next debate where memit oz will be
maybe he has a miracle cure for his
campaign i don't know that'll be
wednesday evening i hope you'll join me
live in a landslide for the next one
you're doing great you're beating the
republicans by
insurmountable numbers and you're
beating joe biden
yeah jody pointing out both of trump's
eyes are almost completely swollen shut
i mean they're just bit
bare slits to the future
until we solve the past because if we
don't solve the past
the same thing's going to happen again
right i mean that's the way i look at it
it's the way i look at it
but watch these elections you know when
i won in texas 33-0
i didn't see any stories written about
it matt not one story now i'm sure there
were a couple you know local papers
if i would have lost two or three
of the races and some of those races
actually were you know they say oh well
they were favored no a lot of those
races a number of those races i picked
underdogs i did it with the senate dr oz
was being swamped by people that have a
lot of money and they were putting and
he was down by 10 points and now he's up
substantially
and jd vance was
being swamped i think he was in fourth
place and now he's up
i i didn't pick people that was your
things at all i don't do it i do what's
right i do what's right and i'm picking
people that are going to win the general
election the networks and the media
trying to this is like watching a
slow-motion train wreck i mean just
there there's no rhyme or reason to
anything he's saying he's just spitting
i just saw
very very big spit coming out of his
mouth too they're looking to do trumpism
without trump who likes trumpism without
trump does anybody i hope
[Music]
does anybody like it
donate plasma i don't think so i don't
know you know sort of
i don't know how it's going to play but
they're working hard at it and even the
new york times said today in a major
article
quote segments featuring fox's own
reporters consistently drew lower
ratings especially if they were covering
stories the audience deemed unavoidable
and unfavorable to trump
so if they took
a story that was unfavorable to trump
their ratings went down do i love the
people i love the people and they love
me i love the people what the hell did i
give up a lot
did i give up a lot but nothing like
this has ever happened i have been under
investigation
for longer periods of time and vicious i
mean in new york state i have this woman
she's a total racist and horrible woman
and i have been yeah that's interesting
the guy with the little girl that seemed
to be not having a good time they're
gone all of a sudden that's interesting
the couple in the upper left of the
screen seems very very close to having
to leave they seem to be having a major
issues and jesse james billy they could
billy the kid and the legendary alphabet
the cut is a cow actually choose its cut
what he had to go through was peanuts
and think of it five years of this crap
and
they got nothing you know why
millions and millions of pages of stuff
nothing nothing they would have done it
in two seconds
and it's so bad it's so they've
weaponized all of that
and it's really uh really amazing but
we're essentially when you think of that
new york times quote we're essentially
does anybody know what he's talking
about i mean in all seriousness does
anyone know what he's talking about
right now if you really do tell me in
the chat piers morgan thank you sir
piers morgan show you see piers morgan
he sort of had it i think piers is
over the hill
he opened the show with an interview of
me i did him a favor i didn't want to do
a stupid show it's on
fox nation what is fox nation what is it
they're going to love me when i say what
is fox it's on fox nation he opened with
great ratings when he did me
and then after my interview was finished
he bombed and he's now down over 70
percent and
maybe they'll someday learn that
maybe they should hire me as an anchor
should i go to work and say we'll get
the greatest reading
imagine trump reading the news
trump does this thing with teleprompters
where he reads it and then he reacts to
it almost as if he's like learning from
the prompter it's it would be
interesting as a news anchor went out
howard was angry at everybody that was
not good
but uh north korea today testing a new
missile
wow that's interesting can you believe
that can you believe these north koreans
u.s intelligence sources say it does not
have the capacity to reach the us
mainland wow well i mean those we know
those people are always right don't we
you know the show in the morning sunday
morning to face face the nation right
or where they have meet the press
i say meet the fake press
they're going to put me in charge of
that
but we have some slides that just came
out from
a great great pulse they're one of the
most respected pollsters trump wants to
show slides of supposed voting evidence
the way people like to show slides of
their you know trip to
trip to the national parks you got to
sit through it yes yes wow incredible in
wisconsin
abc news washington post they said i was
down 17 points and
i mean the fact is
i won the state and i wanted last last
time they said
trump is down by 19 points and i
actually won the state this time i did
better
but they stole it that's the nursing
home story and and many other stories
mexican i said john i said john why do
they say so much why don't they just say
he's down five points six points they
lose credibility he said no they're not
looking they don't care about
credibility if you're down 19 points
people that love you are going to say
you know we love our president but harry
let's go to a movie then we'll come home
and we'll watch television see how it
turned out but when you're down 19
points
it's just as bad as the fake writers
back there when you're down 19 points
people don't vote
so we just got polls out
think of it i'm down 19 points that i
win the state think of that is he
talking about polls right now is he's
not even running for anything what's he
talking about
they'll do anything i said why don't
they do it though five six seven points
he said because you can win if you're
down five points but you can't win if
you're down 19 points so they keep it's
called voter suppression it's a whole
big thing these polls some of these
polls are so fake well look at our
election we won the election twice
but we won the election with polls that
were just crazy and we have some slides
that just came out from a legitimate
pollster john mclaughlin so take a look
oh god look at this oh my god he's
putting up his life does he think
anybody in the crowd is going to be able
to look at that and make any sense out
of it that is absolutely amazing look at
what he's putting up on the screen for
people 50
strongly support
strongly support means you could do
almost anything
guys i know my powerpoint this violates
every every powerpoint convention that
you should adhere to that's pretty good
so that's a very uh that's a very strong
poll 83
look at the section on the right it's
this is unbelievable good
because we had matt schlapp
the crowd's already dead and then he
puts up this this powerpoint oh my god
they did appall
that
very respected star paul i was i came
out 98
approval rating in the republican party
is that right and he's the boss of cpac
except his wife mercedes oh my god
mercedes is actually there this is
actually you this is incredible comedy
putting this up in front of a trump
crowd can you imagine three good one i
just got 98 from cpac put up the
regression analysis please it's unheard
of and what's even more unheard of is 63
strongly support the the people in the
crowd who can read couldn't possibly
read something that small tell you that
all right let's go to the next one next
slide please so this is in the
republican
primary if there was a republican
primary next he's going to go through
slides showing the steps for a knee
replacement oh my god look at this
did they say
they say
uh
good names all good and no a lot of a
lot of good people oh this is the best
liz shaney oh that one what a dynamic
speaker huh
oh look she's at zero percent
she had one month candace owens is on
this poll but generally she's liz shelly
oh that would be a dream i hope that
happens because she's losing so badly
in wyoming you know wyoming was my
number one state
i hate to say nebraska they even topped
you guys
but wyoming and it turns out that liz
cheney happens to be from wyoming and
she's
registering i think david she's at a you
know honestly the interesting trend here
is that desantis's support has gone up
7x in five months like if you if you
want to take seriously that you're
putting up poles at a rally in the sun
where where half the crowd you know
is of unclear uh reading level
desantis went from two to fifteen that's
seven plus x
that's the big story in that so how the
hell does he have 43 i say the poll is
inaccurate
i say it's an accurate call so that's
against uh joe biden the man you just
saw on tape
he gets 43 percent
somebody said i'm winning somebody said
i was up 19 points i said how come 19
well how does he get oh i thought it was
from november to now sorry it was from
last november to now i didn't notice if
that's the case i didn't i didn't notice
that if it was 11 20 20 okay fair that i
i that's my mistake we're only up
we're only up 10 points on her then we
had other people they put i think
crooked hillary clinton and one poll she
didn't do too well
crooked hillary do you see all the fake
stuff that's coming out now i have to
say i have to say john durham is putting
out a lot of you know you look at this
and you just instantly know exactly what
the point of this slide is that's one of
the big powerpoint conventions when
people see the slide they should
immediately know the main point so like
you might put up a slide that just says
it's the economy stupid and then you
talk about it but you look at the slide
and you go i know what this is about
it's about the economy you see those
slides you're like what what's the main
thing i'm supposed to be looking at here
southern border where our country is
being poisoned weakened and permanently
stained
every day biden's open border agenda is
getting innocent americans absolutely
slaughters
just weeks ago an illegal alien was
charged with savagely murdering
a married couple in the prime of their
life for no reason whatsoever they were
riding their bikes near their home in
daytona beach florida he stabbed them
repeatedly mutilated them and dumped
them in a field
horrible thing you saw this story a big
story
happening all over the country in what
was described as one of the most brutal
murders the police had ever seen one of
the policemen i saw him on television he
said i've been doing this for 20 years
i've seen horrible horrible murders i've
never seen anything like this they were
riding their bicycle what a transition
just last week a heroic member of the
texas army national guard specialist
bishop evans
you read about this one too tragically
lost his life in the rio grande after he
jumped in trying to save the lives of
illegal border crosses who turned out to
be
not just border crosses they turned out
to be criminal alien drug smugglers with
tremendous amounts of drugs there were
trafficking and drugs and illicit
narcotics he died he died
the biden administrations
i'm not making light of the subject
matter but this is this speech is
completely unhinged it's it's just it's
a verbal diarrhea it's like an ink blot
under the defund the policeman our
democrat-run cities are also being
ravaged by
the scourge of violence
never forget the radical f wants you to
oh that'll be locked that's a classic
from the covid days the scourge most
dangerous criminals all over our country
without bail and release
repeat offenders without charges
destroying your country your family and
destroying your life
the greatest threat to public health in
our cities is not covet it's the
democrats weak on crime
agenda and policies
record-setting crime is taking place
with shootings and stabbings far more
than covet
in chicago as an example there have been
44 people murdered and 168 people
brutally shot many of them never will
recover compared to 87 deaths for covet
in the last four weeks can you believe
that four weeks democrats are
the party of crime chaos and death
republicans are the part and i think
this is pretty well that was a glitch
republicans of the party of law order
and life
they call for people who haven't even
been charged with anything to be locked
up and he claims to be for law and order
republicans at every single level
right here in nebraska you have the
chance to elect a die hard
maggot champion as your governor a man
who's been with us
trump seems bored by his own speech
that's true
charles w herbster
i first got to know charles when he was
one of my earliest supporters
and made him the chair of my agriculture
advisory committee of
200 2016. i'll tell you he did a great
job
he did a great job he was so into it he
wanted to help the farmer
as a fifth generation nebraska farmer
and rancher who really knows his
business
he had great careers in business and
other things everything he did was
successful no one will
fight for this state harder than charles
he's
a person that happens to love the state
of nebraska wow most importantly charles
w he sounds so bored by this medio the
radical left that's why they're doing
everything they can to stop him
[Applause]
charges
to derail him long enough that the
election can go by there's a question in
the chat that is so much more
interesting than anything being said
what is my go-to deli order my go-to
deli order is pastrami on
pumpernickel or malt marble rye
with mustard
with mustard
charles welcome to politics
beautiful nice business isn't it
you know after i won the election and
16 friends of my tough guys business
people i used to think these were the
toughest people these guys were tough
they're from new york real estate guys
and i used to go around saying oh
business these businessmen are the
toughest and women and
brown spicy brown mustard guys of course
yeah different hoaxes that came up
russia russia russia turned out to be a
fake story think of it it's a fake story
and they have it now as a fake and
people are being indicted all over the
place they made up the story i kept
saying people would say to me during the
campaign sir uh
sure do you know anything about russia
sir sure
and this is during the campaign right
and i'd say uh i mean yeah i can tell
you where it is dave i don't
know too much about it you know i
thought it was just an innocent question
but after you get asked a question like
seven times and young people would come
up matt schlapp called me asked me a
question sir what do you know about
russia i'm saying what the hell is going
on with russia
it was a fake story that was put out
there and this wouldn't go away we
wasted two years on that fake story and
now we caught them and we caught them in
the air i think that that fake story
generated two dozen uh indictments
and recovered more money than it cost
state is very poorly represented by a
grandstanding little respected senator
called little ben sass he's bad
who's an embarrassment
to the people of nebraska he's a total
embarrassment
this guy started off this little ben
says he's so lightweight he started off
so nasty to me i won the presidency and
i met with the 52 at the time senators
and everybody was nice i helped
mcconnell get elected without me
mcconnell would have lost by the way and
i helped numerous of them get elected
but this little ben says ask me a
question what do you know about
the military i said what do i know about
i just got elected president it's a
nasty question he said this in front of
you 52 republicans david you're afraid
i've never told this i don't think but
this little wise guy well what do you
know about this what do you know about
health care you've never done it before
i just got elected president i said who
is that little guy back there
i said i never saw him before they said
his name is ben sasse
ben sass he's from nebraska i said he's
a
i said he's a fresh
i said he's a fresh son of a [ __ ] isn't
he though
i was like girl with me
i said uh i said you're a nasty guy you
know that right
well i'm your serger like i said he was
very bad for a year then all of a sudden
the people started to speak he said he
was going down the tubes so lindsey
graham ted cruz and some others came
over and they said
could he'd love to meet you would you be
willing to mean i said i really don't
want to meet him i mean if but anyway he
came over to the white house he was
groveling right
because you were letting him know that
he was not long for this world
and he apologized and he could not have
been nicer for two years okay
and then it came time isn't telling
someone they're not long for this world
like a threat to kill them in some way
or that they're going to die i guess
and
it was like a net you know
get him off
get him off my ass
but this guy's leaving
but he was fine people are filing out
did you guys see that side shot people
are filing out this guy's leaving
wow who endorsed me he's going to be
good would you endorse him he was
begging for the endorsement
and you know the head of your republican
party is not a fan of this guy and he
called me he said after the fact he said
i wish you would have told us you
couldn't stand this guy we would have
run somebody against him we would have
won i said well i wish i would have done
that and frankly i wish i would have
done it to mitch mcconnell also because
we would have wanted to get that
but we didn't
so they treat you nice and then you give
them an endorsement and he won and the
day after he won remember this he came
out trump should not have removed troops
from germany we had 54 000 troops in
germany they're delinquent on their
payments to nato they're paying half
what they should be paying we're
defending them they screw us on cars
i mean when was the last time they sold
the chevrolet i asked angela why would
germans buy a chevrolet guys please
please last time you sold a chevrolet
and
bmw audi
volkswagen mercedes
people are going to go give me a chevy
no offense guys but that's what they
want that's what they need in germany
from many years ago
and yet they sell mercedes benz yeah bmw
wonder volkswagen by the millions and
millions they don't take our farm
product europe you know europe
is not much better than china was on
trade
so i went down and i said uh you know we
have 54 000 soldiers porsche over in
germany that's a lot of soldiers that's
like a city
and they make a fortune because the
soldiers get paid and they go out and
they buy in the stores and they do all
this stuff and they didn't treat us
right they haven't treated they've been
very bad on trade so i said we're going
to remove 25 000 soldiers from germany
and you know angela how do you think we
can convince the german people to leave
their german cars and buy chevys
i don't know give them to them for free
ben sass comes the day after the
election and he starts criticizing me
and removing soldiers from germany and
you know germany's going to be just fine
they're going to be just fine but i'll
never forget it the guy wins his
election and then he hits me so little
bed sass is bad news another one that i
think is bad news is your guy don bacon
i think he's bad
and i hope you vote like hell against
that guy he's bad news he's always
chirping in the background never
constructive
just an otherwise guy like little ben
sass
and i wish i would have known your
republican chairman he was very good he
was great he said you know if you would
have told us i said no you should have
told me i wish you told me
i said did you have anybody he said no
but we would have had somebody and they
would have beaten ben says
with don bacon i think it would have
been the same actually you have a
gentleman
running i think he's here right right
you know i was taking pictures backstage
and he's a nice guy keel steve keel he's
a nice guy
now i don't know steve
i don't know stephen
look at pillow hi steve how are we here
we're doing a classic action lawsuit
against all machines she loves him so
much she's like tears are coming down
her eyes
he loves nebraska he loves nebraska
steve keel
it's pronounced keel
but it's spelled
k-u-e-h-l how the hell did you get keel
out of that one right
but he's just a really nice guy and i
just met him and uh you know i have no
idea how he's gonna do uh bacon's been
there for a long time
but he's just
he's just he's not good so i'm not
endorsing one way or the other i know
nothing but i've heard great i know
nothing there it he's finally being
honest now you know guys i think one of
the biggest problems facing nebraskans
right now is uh low-flow shower heads
and toilets that don't power flush and i
really would like to hear trump address
that issue steve whoever the hell you
are
okay and now his wife is happy i wanted
to make her stop crying
i i wanted to stand up wife
wife i wanted
i wanted to make her stop crying and now
she's happy as hell that's good wow what
a slur
fest
if ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
i'd be dating her of a
stinging rebuke to the rhinos and the
sellouts and the losers and you got a
bunch of stand-up wife is similar to
when he said where's my african-american
during a rally that's gonna
do well in your negotiations with
foreign countries who take advantage of
nebraska and every place else which also
not going to be taking advantage i can
tell you that much right now
he may be actually too aggressive if if
you don't like him being too aggressive
you probably shouldn't vote for him but
he's being too aggressive it looks like
more people are leaving check it out
more people just like so many so much
shifting to get let people out business
life and other things and i'd like to
have him come up he's really somebody
that's been put through a grinder and
it's very unfair he's a high quality
person now remember the trick during
these little opportunities
is
you have to speak for under a minute and
at least 30 seconds have to praise trump
or he gets visibly bored and he might
reject the endorsement
i stood at trump tower on june 16th of
2015 when donald j trump
and melania trump came down the
escalator and i said to my wife judy you
have just met the next president of the
united states of america
and then he said mexicans are rapists
and criminals and i said this man is a
god people
running
in the republican party
for the president of the united states
of america one by one they just dropped
by dominoes
[Applause]
five presidents promised they would move
the embassy to jerusalem
and on may 18th of 2018
donald j trump moved the embassy to
jerusalem
more so first of all i can't imagine any
of the crowd even understands the
significance of that but more
interestingly jared was going to solve
the israeli-palestinian conflict nobody
talks about that failed promise anymore
along with the fact that he appointed
to the supreme court of the united
states of america three conservative
supreme court justices
thank you this guy's got the accent down
pat i mean it's absolutely perfect the
way he's able to do it
so notice the entire speech was praising
trump that's how you're expected to do
it
that's pretty good charles
so
early voting is already underway
and the primary as you know early voting
is underway which is completely
fraudulent and we should end it but
please go and vote if he does you'll be
very happy and you're going to have an
even more prosperous uh people in the
chat saying didn't i support moving the
embassy no i did not job and if i didn't
feel that i wouldn't be here and it's
not even about the friendship i do have
a feeling because he was right there
right at the beginning he was able to
predict it
but he's going to do a fantastic job so
get out and vote for charles w herbster
herpster
the herpster was the nickname for a guy
i went to college with who was suspected
of uh
harboring a number of stds they called
them the herpster it's the state of
missouri and this gentleman is
congressman billy long do you know that
you know billy billy stand up billy
he's been
a great friend of ours he's another one
right from
the beginning
thank you billy guys i'm sorry this
guy's last name should be wide not long
i'm so i i couldn't help it guys i know
that that's sort of out of school but it
was too obvious order again right from
the beginning he was a hell of a
football player jack brewer jack thank
you
thank you very much
thank you
amanda everybody in the chat thought it
guys i know i know and paul anybody
anytime i get a 98 poll i like that guy
i don't care but i do like him and i've
liked him for a long time i've liked him
before he was the head of cpac
and his wife is incredible worked in the
white house with us mercedes
matt schlapp matt
thank you
another longtime friend of mine and
david i think you were there right just
about at the beginning right will he
introduce pillow or not sometimes he
does sometimes he doesn't what do you
guys think we're actually there before
the beginning like we're not going to
vote unless this guy from new york named
trump
unless he's the only guy going to win
so uh and we did do much better the
second time you have to say much better
but he's the head of citizens united the
job he's done is
incredible and uh i really hope you're
gonna go see the documentary he made on
zuckerberg
uh it's it's really it's really
incredible what these guys are like oh
god i just lost 12 paid members over mr
wide took place in a certain state that
you know very well
nebraska where they put a man
they want to put a congressman in jail
over a tiny amount of money i don't know
i don't know what the event was i don't
know what the charge it was small
criminality not big criminality in
california which is a little strange
and it was over
a very small amount here's a group of
people i know nothing about it but you
know it looked like a very very unfair
prosecution
but here's a guy
think of it who put up
417 million dollars
and nothing happens with the other one
you're talking about
thousands of dollars
and he said he didn't know about it uh
so it's a very
sad
double standard another man who's a
friend of mine who's a real patriot he
really is and he's a great gentleman i
call him the greatest purchaser of
advertising
i think he makes the best deal i would
love him to buy
if there's a next campaign which i
suspect you people think there will be i
should have him buy our ads
because we will get
we will get more
more
success out of a dollar i've never seen
a guy like this he can buy more ads i
mean the pillow business must be a very
profitable business
mike lindell he's been a friend right
from the beginning we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
oh god
even when george w bush was president we
wouldn't have believed that this is what
the republican party would become i
don't know how to heli by so much but
boy he's he's a good negotiator and he's
a he's a man that knows and understands
the election very well and what took
place he's a patriot with the help of
many people here tonight over four
incredible years ago we grew the
conservative movement into a
working people's movement now remember
trump's movement is not conservative
it's
neo-reactionary there it's just they're
just not a conservative movement did
this party to a level that that's why
they say we want the party we want
everything we just don't want trump by
the way that's the liberal media saying
that that's not the people saying it
that's why that's we call it trumpism
without trump
and we're never going back our movement
must continue to pursue a populist and
nationalistic
[Applause]
and you can do that other thing normally
or at the third element of the bathroom
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender transgender
[Applause]
thank you by the way this is not only a
big crowd look at those beautiful fields
of corn and every this is so beautiful
you're so lucky to be growing up i've
seen things where i grew up that are a
little tough
you don't have those things happening in
your community you're very lucky and
you're very talented too you have an
incredible law enforcement group who i
met backstage by the way thank you to
the police and to your fire department
thank you
thank you to the fire department
our movement must continue to pursue a
populist and nationalist economic agenda
that puts working families before
globalist politicians that are fools
and corrupt multinational corporations a
lot of these people like this guy to me
republican from pennsylvania i wouldn't
give him my endorsement and he didn't
run he did nothing at all except fight
me on taxing china
i said let me ask you pat
i want to charge china
taxes and or tariffs you can call
whatever you want to me it's very
similar
because either way it's american
companies paying them do that why can't
i do that let me ask you if they have a
car and they charge 50 or 100 or
something else and they're charging a
hundred percent and i have the same
product going the opposite direction and
i want to charge a hundred percent don't
sir that's not free trade
china
i said so they can charge we can't and
you don't want to make any man supposing
i charge them not 100 but 25 is that
okay no sir that's not free and fair
trade sir
china so i wouldn't give him my
endorsement and he actually voted to
impeach me can you believe it this guy
that was before the fact
i decided i couldn't wait you know when
they wanted me to endorse him i said no
thanks and i knew i had a vote coming up
that shows i'm legit look i know i would
have done it the right thing to do in
terms of being smart but i'm an honest
person i said i'm not going to endorse
him he can vote any way he wants and we
had great support in the senate and we
had incredible support in the republican
house we had just incredible support and
i want to thank we went through this
thing twice
we went through bill bart didn't want to
be impeached he's how do you not trump
has been speaking 75 minutes already
starting to put this on the longer end
of his speeches do you believe he will
go over 90 minutes let me know in the
chat i actually say no i think you have
to have courage
if we're going to win you have to have
courage so i said no i'm not going to
support him knowing a vote's coming up i
mean like i'm a smart guy knowing
actually you know what he's rambling so
much i'm gonna say yes he did vote
against for no reason whatsoever by the
way and you know with the house
six down and four to go
that's those are the ten impeachers
right the tender pictures the liz
cheney's and
and the adam crying kenzinger you ever
seen this guy's always crying
he's should see a psychiatrist
yes this guy he's crying is an obvious
sign you should immediately see a
psychiatrist
but he's out he quit
gonzales quit a lot of them quit
guyan
guy in
south carolina's just getting absolutely
pummeled you know he voted he voted in
south carolina like i think it's a trump
plus 28th district i don't know we're up
by a lot
and he voted and he voted we're up by a
lot what what
where what race is that it's hammered he
said i never knew i was gonna commit
political suicide over this
but his name is rice rice congressman
rice from south carolina he's getting
hammered now and they have a great
candidate against them so we're doing
good we're doing good but i just feel
that that's not acceptable what they did
we've done a great job and to vote
with the democrats on a scam impeachment
thing because nancy pelosi and the
democrats say what you want they're
horrible their policy is horrible but
they do stick together they stick
together like glue
we stood up for nebraska like no
president in history we ended the
disaster known as nafta the worst trade
deal ever made in the history of our
country
and we replaced it with the usmca the
best trade deal ever there is almost no
difference between nafta and usmca there
are some modest changes dealing with the
automobile industry but it is basically
the same thing to it so much anymore
because i left and they don't give a
damn about this administration
but we made a great deal we made both
great deals in fact be careful because
they want to renegotiate the usmca
mexico and china they want to
renegotiate you've probably been reading
they say the deal's not fair isn't it
nice that finally we have a deal where
another country is saying
they moved blacks for trump guy
trump was actually hiding blacks for
trump guy
from the camera because he was right in
front of him and they've now moved him
into a position where he's more visible
kind of like no one has ever stood up to
them taking in billions and billions of
dollars in taxes and tariffs
and we gave of the billions and billions
and billions we took in money
we gave 28 billion dollars to the
farmers you know that right because i
said let me ask you
i was with a very
good secretary perdue i was with a very
good man i said how much what was the
most money
that china purchased from us prior to
them going on like a strike they didn't
want to do business
and he said 28 it was i guess it was 14
and 14 or 12 and 16.
28 billion dollars i said that's okay
when the money starts pouring in i'm
giving 28 billion
billion dollars to the farmers and i
gave you 28 billion dollars
and i see that
[Music]
i see that beautiful john deere tractor
back there and if you remember what i
said because you know what i love about
the farmers they stood with me
all the way they never
complained they said look it's tough
well i was negotiating because china was
essentially not doing what they should
do and they were boycotting and they
weren't buying anything they thought
they were going to force me out that i'd
lose the farm support and it was just
the opposite the farmer stood with me i
don't know if you know about this david
they stood with me i was in the white
house so we had 35 farmers come in
i said i'm going to get you so much
money i'm going to and i said to them is
a tomato really a fruit i don't know
guys china and we're going to do some
subsidy to the farmers and
three of them looked at me sir we don't
want subsidy we just want a level
playing field
i said you got to be kidding me that's
the first time i've ever heard anyone
say that everyone wants to get they just
want freebies the only one that ever
said that to me were the farmers we
don't want subsidies just give us a
level playing field so i gave them more
than a level playing field i gave them
i gave them a level playing field that
looked like this it was a glide scope
but uh they were incredible i've never
forgotten this glidescope what is that
kaleidoscope what did you say there's
every group they want money
and if i call it subsidy if i call it
whatever they want it the farmers didn't
want i'll never forget it they and they
were virtually unanimous 35 great
farmers good farmers good people some
are friends of mine now
but they said we don't want that sir we
just want a level playing field but i
gave the farmers as you know many of you
are
our beneficiaries 28 billion dollars
because that's what china did to hurt
you for two years and the farmer stood
with me all the time and i love the
farmers love the farmers
but you remember my line i so he he
likes the farmers i guess that's the
real story when so they stopped buying
from our country remember that
i said don't worry about it stick with
me
and you'll have to do one thing what you
have to buy bigger land more land more
acreage and you'll have to get bigger
tractors right
so i said you'll eat you'll need more
land and bigger tractors and i'm looking
at that one that's a pretty big one
right that's pretty big john deere
i'll tell you john deere likes us a lot
that i can tell you sold plenty of big
tractors
we then secured a deal that included the
largest agricultural purchase and orders
in the history of our country china
made the biggest deal after we waited
and we had a year and a half negotiation
and the farmers you know they were being
hurt but i said i'll take care of it a
couple of farmers i watched on one of
the shows the guy said you know i'm
being hurt badly i don't even know if
i'm going to make it but the president's
doing the right thing you got to stop
what they're doing to our country they
were ripping us off but we made a great
deal to save family forms we virtually
eliminated the unfair estate tax or the
death tax on your farms so if you had
good children you want to leave the farm
if you have crappy children to hell with
them don't give them anything
true
we used to talk about it we got rid of
the estate tax on your farm so now
instead of you know what used to happen
before me because it's not that liquid
of business it's like
other things it's a good business but
it's not that liquid you have a valuable
farm but it doesn't throw off the kind
of money the values there so
what i did is i said we got to do
something because people are losing
their farms
because of history of trump's five kids
how many do you think he says are crappy
the kids and the kids would look up and
say
mom and dad what the hell did you leave
me this long for
now they don't have uh estate tax
essentially unless it's a very large
place they don't have a state tax to pay
i mean eric and tiffany he doesn't seem
to like too much and baron he seems to
consider more of just an inconvenience
than anything else congress we got that
approved with the tax bill
i stood up for ethanol and nebraska
ethanol and authorized ethanol producers
to sell e15 and all year around not
eight months that was the craziest thing
there was so this woman's interesting
every couple minutes at not even during
applause lines she picks up a different
sign and just goes
very very interesting what she's up to
from existing pumps you remember what it
was going to be cost so much money to
change the pumps they had to get brand
new pumps i said what's the difference
there is none sir so why are they doing
this i don't know i think it's called
torture
and we let them use the existing pumps
and that's all been done we fought for
nebraska and we won for nebraska and
when we win this november we will fight
and win for nebraska once again and we
will keep winning for nebraska
[Music]
and that means other farm states also
and
frankly it means other states period
whether it's farms or not i treated
nebraska really well and likewise
nebraska treated me yeah we're only
seven minutes from the 90-minute mark i
think you guys are right i think he is
gonna go over 90 minutes today let's you
see what's going on no teacher should
ever be allowed to teach transgender to
our children without
without parental consent you can't teach
transgender this
will soon be over
the speech i hope
we will save our kids and we will also
oh damn now he's going into the wind
down he might he might actually be short
of 90 minutes yeah now i'm going the
other way
[Applause]
i feel so sorry the women you know they
have uh
they had a record of swimming record you
know this a record that lasted for no i
don't know
the the anti-trans rant actually could
take three minutes so now now we may
actually get to 90. woman who wanted to
break it she's a top star
and she thought she could break it by
one-eighth of a second she's gotta do it
and then this dude came in and he swam
he broke the record by
38 seconds right 38. in fact she said
she was
almost injured she got injured by the
wind of him going by her in the pool the
wind she got wind burn
but the best of the weightlifting
records those are the ones i like this
woman i think it was 208 but whatever it
was
and she was great strong
strong i wouldn't want to mess with her
she was strong
and you know they take like a half an
ounce and they put it in the ends
she's going ah
i think it was an 18-year record of some
ridiculous time
didn't make it
this guy comes along
pink
she
could have stood there all day i think
he broke it by was it over a hundred
pounds or something like that so they
were going for one eighth i think they
put an eighth of that's right they
ordered they they added a quarter of an
ounce
to their to the barbells
this is total normalization of open
transphobia i'm breaking these new
records because these new records i'll
tell you what i hate to say this to
women and i don't want to disrespect you
and it's a horrible thing and the fake
news will say what a horrible thing look
they're all standing there oh finally
we're waiting they're waiting for
attention
but if i were a basketball coach
i would have five men on my team i swear
to you because i want to win i'll get
the toughest tallest strongest men in
history
that want to go into the women's sphere
and i will have the greatest and why
hasn't that happened because it's
idiotic
i'll say to lebron james who i don't
like very much i'll say lebron
did you ever have thoughts of going
woman because if you did i'd like to
have you on my basketball court
true
that's true
okay let's get on
in addition we'll get critical race
theory this is gonna be so close on 90
minutes but i do think he will go over
federal state and local government
the radical left democrat party is oh
sorry guys
let's go back to live sorry sorry sorry
i clicked a button trying to see how
long it had been
oh god now it's not starting back up
let's just refresh
here we go they're against god they're
against guns
they're against oil they're against law
enforcement defund the police how stupid
is that
yeah two and a half minutes and he'll be
over 90. he's going over 90. and for
voter id
they're against the constitution and
they're against our
founding fathers that's not a 50
party the only way they win is to cheat
i believe this now some people can
dispute it they cheat in the elections
and they cheat now like never before and
these ballots these paper ballots that
are being sent out by the millions and
millions you'll never ever
be able to control it whether it's
postmen or women and you know both ways
whether it's postmen whether and they
tend to be very democrat they tend to be
that's the way it is for whatever reason
they tend to be very democrat
or any other ways and the ballot
harvesting which is totally illegal what
they do with ballot harvesting if you
and i said this before the election and
we saw it in new york they had some
small elections in new york where they
had mail-in ballots and they still don't
know what the hell happened and that was
a small
congressional election they had an
election in new jersey a ballot election
before the presidential election and to
this day they have no idea what the hell
happened
but you know you take california i think
we do much better in california they all
say that you lose by automatically by
millions of votes i don't believe that i
went to california to just one rally
because i was told don't go to
california i never saw a crowd like that
this crowd was massive massive they sent
out
millions and millions and millions of
ballots
many people got two three four five the
highest i heard was nine wow but they
got many many ballots i don't believe
california is not a winnable state i
think if you had a fair election i think
it's a very winnable state i think we
have a lot of winnable states i don't
think they'd win at all if we had fair
elections that's why
one of the highest priorities for
congress
will be to crack down on the left wing
these are republicans that want to do it
guys like jim jordan is fantastic and
others
jim banks we've got a lot of great
people in congress think of it for the
impeachment hoax number one i think it
was 196 to nothing they stuck together
it's just a hoax right but we have some
great people but they want to crack down
on left-wing censorship and restore free
speech in america and those people back
there are a big problem because they're
so corrupt the press is corrupt
go out and sign up now by the way for
truth did you see truth
truth social
which is number one on the apple app
store betrothed social
for six days now ahead of tick tock
ahead of facebook ahead of all of them
can you imagine this i do this thing and
it's great it's really good the people
love it they love the interaction they
love they love what's going on truth
social go out and sign up because that's
going to be our voice
last week the biden administration
announced they're creating a so-called
disinformation governing board at the
department of homeland security run by
a highly partisan
left-wing lunatic who tried to convince
people that the russia hoax
was true
and that
the hunter biden laptop information was
put out by russia
which he knew was false disinformation
that's what they do disinformation and
if they're just like they do the big lie
while it's the big lie
well there's no proof
while the president i i'm almost ready
to say he's gonna go two hours we've
blown 90 minutes out of the water it's
it's starting to become almost
castro-like or maduro you know these
guys known for these endless speeches
happens to antifa
to black lives matter they kill people
they burn down courthouses federal
courthouses nothing happens it's
like we have two different countries
it's so unfair the democrat parties
brazen desperate attempts at censorship
prove how cowardly they actually are
they are very concerned with mega that i
can tell you and probably they should be
when republicans take back congress the
first thing they will do is to fund this
ridiculous propaganda board
fire the left-wing sensors and terminate
their outrageous violations he hasn't
even gotten to the topic of toilets yet
by the way if the radical left does not
want you to speak why would anyone think
they would want you to vote they don't
want to have you speak they don't want
to have your vote or if they do vote
they want to do something with your vote
how about the people
you know a lot of republicans want to
vote on election day right how about
many women many men but many women would
walk into
i'm here to vote i'm so proud they're so
proud they don't want to vote by fake
ballot they want to go and vote
uh yes ma'am it's nice to have you uh
i'm sorry but you've already voted no
service no no i want to vote today this
is election day november 3rd i want to
vote today a ma'am you've already voted
no i didn't vote
i didn't vote you voted ma'am
you voted we'll give you an absentee
ballot just in case we can prove
otherwise
yeah guys he's well over 90 minutes
already there's still people debating
whether he'll go 90 minutes he's over 90
minutes that that milestone has come and
gone the ballots were for biden
they voted for biden and these were
people that wanted to vote for trump
they were very proud
people and they walked in to vote and
they were told that they were already
voted and so they'd leave
some were angry some were hurt some
cried some just
shuffled their shoulders and said these
are just very dishonest people but
that's what's going on we have no choice
we must restore integrity to our
elections so we don't have a country
between borders and elections we're not
going to have a country any longer we're
poisoning our country
and that means universal voter id
citizenship confirmation
[Music]
no more fake drop boxes
and no private money pouring into local
elections
will we get to a hundred minutes that's
another nine
well we get to a hundred minutes of this
doesn't want it for some reason
we want signature verification
why does kemp and georgia not want that
i can tell you why
just like in france they just had a big
election there were no problems
we should have one day voting with only
paper ballots and absentee ballots
accepted
only from distant military distant
distant military service members or
people who are very sick and they can't
vote okay which is a very small number
of people
france just had it they have paper
ballots no problem
and you know these elections where you
have 48 days and
it starts three weeks early it goes they
want to have them go afterwards much of
it was wasn't even passed by state
legislatures would as you know it has to
be done but these things where they have
storage rooms with boxes and boxes of
votes people walking in and out
sometimes the guard isn't there
sometimes the people aren't there
and then you have the
vote watchers where they throw
republicans out of the election they
throw them out and physically very
strong physically strong people they're
throwing
older people that are patriots out and
scaring the hell out of them what that
took place but we have to have one day
elections again one day no lock boxes no
all this no storage rooms where
yeah when did blacks for trump guy
disappear he's just gone all of a sudden
one day we can do that easily one day we
used to do it for years we did it we
didn't have problems now all of a sudden
you've got 48 days to vote and the votes
are sitting all over the place they're
laying on the floor what a mess this
country's in
let's see i think just keep it where did
he go
they want to do something with your vote
how about the people
you know a lot of republicans want to
vote on election day right how about
many women okay here he goes many women
would walk in the
i'm here to vote i'm so proud they're so
proud they don't want to vote by fake
ballot they want to go and vote checks
his phone uh yes ma'am it's nice to have
you uh i'm sorry but you've already
voted no i haven't no no i want to vote
today this is election day november 3rd
i want to vote today a ma'am you've
already voted no he gets on a phone call
blacks for trump covers his face and is
on a phone call now and then he
disappeared let's see
otherwise i wonder how many of those
ballots we use maybe i would say matt
none do you think any of where were and
if you look at the numbers if you look
at the people okay gets off the phone
over biden
they voted for biden and these are
because they wanted to vote for trump
they were very proud
people and they walked in to vote and
they were told that they were already
voted and so they'd leave
some were angry some were hurt some
cried some just
shuffled their shoulders and said these
are just very dishonest people but
that's what's going on we have no choice
we must restore integrity to our
elections so we don't have a country
between borders and elections we're not
going to have a country any longer we're
poisoning our country
maybe he's just behind trump he will
never let you down oh there he is yeah
he just moved with a republican it's
weird he got a call and then he changed
position that's very interesting like
someone like no you got to be right
behind trump then more american
factories forging more products stamped
with that very beautiful phrase you know
what that is made in the usa thank you
thank you
[Applause]
we will shut down biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in mexico policy how about that
it wasn't easy to get you know how i got
it i said if you don't give it to us
we're going to put tariffs on your cars
coming in they sold 32 of our car making
business over many years not over my
years but over many years i said if you
don't
agree to remain in mexico then we're
going to charge you tariffs and all
those cars that you send us right and
they said we would love to have
everybody remain in mexico sir that
would be a wonderful thing be a
wonderful honor to have all of these
gang members stay in mexico we think
it's great
we will reimpose title 42 which they're
ending it's the most incredible thing
strengthen the patriots of ice and
border patrol we will again end catch
and release we will end chain migration
a disaster we will end the visa
melania's parents are in the u.s due to
chain migration she got an einstein visa
and subsequently citizenship then then
she brought her parents with chain
migration included human trafficking
mostly women by the way i have to tell
you
yeah a lot of children but mostly it was
women they had the human trafficking
women
and we had the drug numbers down to the
lowest point they've been in in decades
and now they're the highest and the
worst numbers because you just drive in
nobody's there we have no idea who they
are
they can have drugs they can have
children they can have women
we just they just drive into our country
it's horrible we'll quickly
finish the remainder of the wall that we
started because again i told you we
finished the wall but we decided to do
more
three weeks it would be finished they're
60 miles in 2 000 to go
i thought it was impossible that they
wouldn't do that they wouldn't even let
texas use the pieces that were sitting
there ready to be installed
and they said you can't do it they took
it away and they moved it to an area
that's miles away we will stop the
democrat crime wave we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect they deserve
and we will not take
legal protection away from them they
want to take legal protection away from
the police so that everybody every time
a policeman a policewoman
anybody gives a parking ticket and they
get sued they have to defend themselves
can you i'm not aware that police give
parking tickets isn't that usually just
parking enforcement like they don't have
guns they're not police
we'll hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world we
will protect innocent life we will
defend our constitution and we will
defend our second amendment which is
under siege
and we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor
their history and always respect our
great american flag
this is the wind down
in conclusion our maga movement make
america great again is by far the
greatest political movement in the
history of our country and you know i
say it all the time he's over a hundred
minutes already it is because i was just
a little bit off there'd be headlines
tonight tomorrow
together we're standing up against some
of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people have ever seen
despite great outside dangers and we do
have outside dangers what's happening
with russia and ukraine is a tremendous
outside danger our biggest threat
remains the sick
sinister and evil people from within our
country
they're a bigger threat
than the outside threat but no matter
how big or powerful these corrupt
radical politicians may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them this nation belongs
to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and
our american liberty is your god-given
right they're not going to take it away
from lincoln to omaha
from norfolk to hastings
and from grand island to right here in
greenwood
you inherit the legacy of generations of
great nebraska patriots it's a great
state they're great people you built
america who gave their blood sweat and
tears for their country that they loved
so much
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who cross the oceans
settle the continent tame the wilderness
lay down the railroads raised up those
skyscrapers
won two world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america the single greatest nation
in the history of the world
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country from the most
horrible things that are right now
happening we are going to fight for
america like no one has ever fought
before
we will stand up
to the radical left lunatics and the
rhinos and we will preserve protect and
defend the heritage that has
been of use of the term heritage for
nearly
250 years think of that
there's no
mountain we cannot climb
there like the black folks on stage
thinking what was my
ancestor's heritage in this country 250
years ago let me think is that what we
want we will not bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never ever
back down
as long as we are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not
even stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and to god alone
my fellow citizens
[Music]
this incredible journey that we've been
on together has only just begun
it's time to start talking about
greatness for our country again we don't
talk about greatness we talk about
everything we don't talk about greatness
our country didn't become great by
talking about other things
we are one movement
one people one family and one glorious
nation
under god and we're never taking the
name god out we are not taking it out
they want god
they want god taken out they want god
removed
so with the help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land
we will make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america great again
thank you nebraska thank you thank you
charles thank you
[Music]
there it is
wow
[Music]
so an extremely long rally it clocked in
at let's see where it ended
right about
105 minutes about 105 minutes long
[Music]
and uh yeah i mean might as well gone
too i have gone two hours right it's
like you were so
close blacks for trump guy getting a
special hello from trump there
an extremely disturbing speech
in an extremely disturbing place to be
perfectly frank
uh i'll be live wednesday with the
pennsylvania republican senate primary
debate probably do some johnny depp
coverage tomorrow and tuesday oh god
he's got new moves and they're really
weird
[Music]
a little bit of a chris farley
vibe
a lot of the people here look very
disturbed no there's no doubt about it i
won't point to any specifically but
um this kid here is interesting
[Applause]
i want to be careful because quite
frankly like a lot of a lot of this is
man it's just it's tough to talk about
but there's a lot of undiagnosed autism
that comes with an obsessive element and
sometimes they get obsessed with trump
and it's just like yeah i'm i you don't
it's not it's not a thing of making fun
of anybody
um but there's just a lot of stuff going
on a lot of stuff going on
[Applause]
[Music]
really sad stuff
anyway there goes trump there goes trump
the the country really a shadow of its
former self
uh and this movement continues
we uh i can't thank everybody enough who
joined me welcome to all of our new
twitch followers and twitch subscribers
so many of you signing up i really
really really appreciate that
um everybody who has subscribed on
youtube of course and 133 people getting
either twitch prime subscriptions or
website memberships
be glad that you were not at this rally
because it will take some of these
people hours to leave hours to leave
we can just shut it off
and go
and do what we need to do and that is a
really really great thing we don't want
to be stuck there like these people uh
have a good night everybody good rest of
your afternoon depending on where you
are good morning to everybody
uh in australia
and in various parts of asia
and uh man
what what a depressing what a depressing
site i'll see everybody back here soon
podcast tomorrow clips
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
yep all right see everybody very soon
and we